la séance est reprise
alors la parole est à Monsieur Alain
Huppert pour une mise au point au sujet
d'un vote
merci bien la présidente ce sujet du
vote sur le scrutin public numéro 158 où
je souhaitais tout simplement m'abstenir
merci de prendre acte
mise au point sera publié au Journal
officiel qu'il y aura dans l'analyse
politique du scrutin concerné la parole
maintenant est à Monsieur Olivier
Hainaut pour également une mise au point
au sujet d'un vote merci madame la
Présidente à mon tour je souhaite
procéder au nom de Nathalie Goulet une
rectification de vote sur l'amendement
4469 au scrutin et le dans le numéro est
159 et Nathalie Goulet souhaitait voter
pour je vous remercie merci à tes
données de votre mise au point qui sera
également publié au Journal officiel
figuiera dans l'analyse politique du
scrutin concerné
alors nous reprenons la discussion du
projet de loi de financement
rectificative de la sécurité sociale
pour 2023 dans la discussion des
articles nous sommes parvenus à la
présentation de l'amendement numéro
3738 au sein de l'Arctique le 2 et donc
monsieur Ferny vous avez la parole
donc c'est un moment 3738 donc par du
principe que l'absence de cadre
juridique précis et défini sur l'étendue
et les modalités les indicateurs de
l'index senior cela pourrait entraîner
des risques de contournement c'est assez
évident du dispositif par les
entreprises nous devons tirer des
lotions de l'index d'égalité homme-femme
créée en 2018 et qui n'a guère favorisé
concrètement l'application de la Loi sur
la qualité salariale on constate que ces
mécanismes incitatifs manquent
d'efficacité
afin de rendre donc l'index senior plus
contraignant il est donc indispensable
de pouvoir contrôler de façon stricte la
mise en place et la conformité des
indicateurs des actions mises en œuvre
pour favoriser l'emploi des seniors tel
est l'objet de cette amendement merci
alors deux amendements identiques
monsieur Bruyer
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues je présente cet
amendement au nom de mon collègue Thomas
dessus qui ne pouvait être présent ce
soir
il s'agit après la Linéa 8 d'insérer un
alinéa ainsi rédigé la mise en place la
conformité et la transmission des
indicateurs ainsi que les actions mises
en œuvre pour favoriser l'emploi des
seniors font l'objet d'un contrôle dans
l'année suivant la date de sa mise en
application je voudrais insister sur le
fait que cet amendement est beaucoup
moins contraignant que la volonté
gouvernementale qui est prête à
sanctionner des entreprises qui
n'auraient pas déposé leur index dès la
première année sans doute pour pouvoir
inscrire les recettes au projet de loi
de finances rectificative
2023 est justifiée ainsi de ce texte
compte tenu du manque de précision sur
l'étendue et les modalités des
indicateurs les risques de contournement
du dispositif par les entreprises sont
réelles
c'est dans l'optique que c'est index
senior soit un outil réellement
contraignant pour les entreprises que
nous proposons de mettre en place des
contrôles stricts de son application de
l'élaboration des réponses aux
indicateurs et des mesures mises en
oeuvre pour remédier au manquement en
matière d'emploi des seniors telle est
l'objet de cette amendement merci et le
42001 même Cohen
oui merci madame la Présidente nous
entendons que la mise en œuvre la
conformité la transmission des
indicateurs ainsi que les actions de
garantie de l'emploi des seigneurs soit
l'objet d'un contrôle dans l'année
suivant la date de l'application de
l'index ça nous semble extrêmement
important pour la protection des seniors
sinon ça sera l'être morte la question
du contrôle des réponses aux indicateurs
et vraiment extrêmement importante il se
fait partie de la vraiment de du cœur en
quelque sorte de ces index seniors si on
veut qu'il soit un tant soit peu
efficace sinon ça va être biaisé et ça
risque de de ne pas protéger les seniors
comme on voudrait le faire
merci alors troisième amendements
identiques
197 madame Joseph jugonet
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
ministère collègues on parle ici de la
particularité du sport professionnel
l'index senior poursuit l'objectif
d'améliorer l'insertion de cette
population sur le marché du travail mais
il présente un écueil majeur concernant
son application au club professionnel
les carrières sportives professionnels
sont particulièrement courtes en moyenne
inférieure à 7 ans et pouvant également
être stoppée brutalement suite à une
blessure au regard de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite par ailleurs afin
d'assurer les meilleurs performances les
sportifs professionnels effectuent leur
carrière en moyenne entre 18 et 30 ans
et les contrats sont par définition à
durée déterminée à la fin de leur
contrat les sportifs joueurs et
entraîneurs ne peuvent pas tous
bénéficier d'un reclassement sur des
postes administratifs administratifs
internes aussi à la lumière de ces
éléments la mise en place d'un index
senior n'est pas adapté aux spécificités
du sport professionnel et si les
entreprises sont redevables d'une
pénalité c'est tout un secteur
d'activité qui serait menacé enfin le
souhait du gouvernement de laisser la
possibilité aux branches d'organiser la
mise en place de l'index senior ne
permettrait pas de le limiter aux
fonctions administratives cet amendement
propose donc d'inscrire dans la loi
l'application de cet index aux structure
sportive uniquement sur la population
dite administrative en excluant les
sportifs joueurs et entraîneurs de son
périmètre merci le 233 même présidente
billon merci madame la Présidente donc
cet amendement de notre collègue Claude
Kern et
identique à celui qui vient de défendre
notre collègue Jean Raymond Hugonnet
donc il est défendu je vous remercie
merci le 1012 même Brésil merci madame
la présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues c'est effectivement un
amendement
identique qui vise donc à ce que cette
index di senior s'applique aux
structures sportives professionnelles
uniquement sur la population
administrative en excluant expressément
les sportifs joueurs et entraîneurs de
son périmètre d'appréciation
merci deux amendements identiques le
2787 monsieur
oui merci madame la Présidente est
amendement du groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains vise à
majorer le taux de cotisation à
l'assurance arrêt de travail maladie
professionnelle des employeurs ne
respectant pas l'index senior se des 50
salariés d'après la DARES seulement 33 %
des personnes âgées de 60 à 63 ans sont
en emploi en France en 2022 contre 45%
dans l'ensemble de l'Union européenne
70% en Suède le taux d'emploi de la
tranche d'âge 55 64 ans s'élève lui à
56%, mais reste inférieure de près de 5
points à la moyenne des pays de l'Union
européenne
or d'après la chair transition
démographique augmentée de 10 points le
taux d'emploi des seniors d'ici à 2030
permettrait de déshormer le déficit des
retraites d'ici 2030 quelque soit le
scénario du corps
à l'heure actuelle les taux de
cotisations des entreprises pour les
accidents du travail et les maladies
professionnelles varie déjà en fonction
de leur taille et de leur sinistralité
dès lors une mod une modulation à la
hausse selon leurs résultats à l'index
peut s'avérer particulièrement incitatif
merci merci le 425 même Cohen
merci madame la Présidente une note de
l'Institut de recherche et de
documentation en économie de la santé
sur l'état de santé des seniors dans les
entreprises a été réalisées à partir
d'une étude auprès de 22 000 personnes
âgées de 50 ans et plus vivant dans 10
pays européens dont la France cette
étude illustre les conséquences de
l'évolution des conditions de travail au
cours des dernières décennies dans ces
pays développés cette évolution s'est
accompagnée de l'apparition de nouvelles
formes d'organisations du travail
pouvant être source de pénibilité et de
risques pour la santé dans un contexte
de vieillissement de la population ces
problèmes sont particulièrement
préoccupants en matière d'emploi de
santé et de financement des retraites
les relations entre le travail et la
santé sur le long terme appelle la
réalisation d'autres recherches dans le
domaine de la prévention des risques
organisationnels dans les entreprises
les liens entre l'état de santé et le
fait de déclarer par exemple un salaire
insuffisant l'absence de perspective de
progression personnelle le manque de
soutien dans les situations de travail
difficile et l'insécurité de l'emploi
sont les plus significatifs parmi les
seniors les femmes sont plus souvent
concernées par l'insécurité de l'emploi
et le manque de soutien au travail enfin
les maladies chroniques sont plus
fréquentes pour les hommes ayant peu de
perspectives de progression personnelle
pour les femmes ces maladies sont plus
fréquentes lorsqu'elles considèrent
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure leur
salaire trop faible relativement aux
efforts fournis et lorsqu'elles ont peur
de ne pas garder leur emploi ainsi la
santé des seniors en emploi paraît
fortement liée aux composantes du
travail dès lors les caractéristiques de
l'organisation du travail la santé
constitue des déterminants importants de
la participation des seniors au marché
du travail pour ces raisons il est
indispensable de majorer les cotisations
accidents du travail maladie
professionnelle des entreprises d'au
moins 50 salariés si les résultats de
leur index seniors ne sont pas
satisfaisants je vous remercie
si alors deux amendements
identiques le 3740 monsieur Ferny
merci Madame présidente monsieur le mini
chers collègue donc deux apports
principaux de cet amendement il propose
d'une part d'établir un barème et un
score minimum à atteindre d'autre part
de conditionner les exonérations de
cotisations prévues à l'obtention de
résultats satisfaisants au-dessus d'un
seuil minimal qui sera défini par décret
et enfin alors que les dispositifs
d'exonération de cotisation la science
maladie dont bénéficie des employeurs se
sont multipliés sans pour autant
démontrer leur efficacité il paraît
raisonnable de conditionner de tels
exonérations à des efforts quantifiables
permettant de parvenir à une
amélioration de l'emploi des seniors
merci 4213
à Monsieur zoulou
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur Miss
mais mes chers collègues nous pensons de
façon générale que les aides de l'État
doivent être soumises à des
contreparties et c'est pour ça que comme
l'a dit notre collègue nous souhaitons
par cet amendement conditionné la
réduction de cotisations d'assurance
maladie à six points pour les salaires
inférieur à 2,5 fois le SMIC à
l'obtention d'une note satisfaisante
calculée en fonction des index de cet
article 2 merci Madame présidente merci
3739 monsieur ferrique
la présidente l'absence de mesure
réellement rigoureuse ne donnerait guère
de crédit à l'index senior en l'état il
aurait un impact d'autant plus faible
que l'obligation ne porte on sait que
sur sa publication et non sur
l'obtention de résultats satisfaisant il
est donc nécessaire de prévoir des
sanctions financières basées sur les
résultats il y a adapté à la taille aux
ressources des entreprises concernées
nous proposons donc d'établir un barème
d'évaluation des indicateurs et
d'établir des sanctions en cas de
résultat insuffisants différenciés selon
la taille et le chiffre d'affaires de
l'entreprise merci deux amendements
identiques le 421
7 si madame la Présidente il existe un
petit tour de passe-passe argumentatif
dans lequel se baigne patron de grande
entreprise et classe sociale riche celui
de faire comme s'il parle pour tout le
monde ainsi ils font croire au ménage
qui ont tout sacrifié pour une petite
maison qu'une réforme de l'héritage les
touchera et les dépoussa comme les
patrons d'Empire industriel disent
qu’une réforme sur les bénéfices
s'accumulera le boulanger il est temps
que cela cesse c'est une mystification
et une mauvaise foi grâce au vu des
enjeux c'est pour nous
c'est pour nous passer de ce genre de
plainte et de larmes de crocodile que
nous vous proposons cet amendement qui
induit une modulation et des délais de
mise en conformité avec les attendus
d'un niveau minimal d'emploi des seniors
et du montant des sanctions nous
instituts nos institutions nous
instituts aux trois groupes à l'instar
des définitions de l'Insee le premier
concernera la plupart de notre tissu
économique puisque nous en fixons le
seuil à l'emploi de moins de 250
salariés soit si je prends les chiffres
de 2007 plus de 4 millions d'unités
légales les PME n'auront donc pas les
mêmes obligations que les entreprises de
taille intermédiaires qui étaient en
2018 près de 5700 que les grands que les
grandes entreprises qui étaient 269
toujours en 2018 maintenant c'est dit
j'ajoute que nous sommes prêts à voter
le renforcement des moyens humains via
l'emploi de fonctionnaires de
l'inspection du travail pour
l'information et aux petites entreprises
pour le premier groupe donc nous fixons
à un an délai de mise en conformité le
deuxième groupe huit mois et le
troisième groupe six mois notre
attention est simple claire et précise
la responsabilité d'autant plus grande
que l'entreprise les car le maintien des
seniors est plus facilement réalisable
eu égard au nombre de métiers différents
de services variés et de moyens
d'adapter les postes de travail je vous
remercie merci le 4657 madame Vogel
merci madame la Présidente dans la copie
remise au Sénat l'indique l'index senior
reste très flou et par conséquent un
outil malheureusement impuissant est
loin de la hauteur des enjeux en effet
ces alinéas ne fait 10 de l'article dont
nous sommes en train de discuter reste
très flou parce que certes on prévoit
une sanction dans la limite de 1% des
rémunérations et gains quand une
entreprise ne publie pas d'index mais le
projet de loi de détaille pas
précisément à quel moment cette
obligation de publier l'index est
remplie et à quel moment elle ne l'est
pas et ça ouvre la porte à des abus dans
la mesure où les entreprises
pourrait se conformer uniquement
partiellement en espérant que le flou
laissé par le législateur leur permettra
d'échapper à toute sanction de plus ces
deux alinéas incident guèrent les
entreprises à un changement ils
prévoient tout simplement le paiement le
paiement d'une pénalité dans la limite
d'un pourcent ok mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe ensuite si il y a
récidive est-ce que la pénalité augmente
si l'entreprise ne publie pas d'index
seniors deux années de suite 5 dizaines
le projet de loi reste très flou à ce
sujet et donc c'est un moment vise à
clarifier les dispositions sur la
pénalité de l'index seniors concrètement
nous proposons qu'un seuil minimum
d'emploi de seniors soit fixés par
décret pour qu'on ait des objectifs en
de cette ce seuil l'entreprise serait
réputée non conforme et devra donc payer
une pénalité de plus nous proposons une
pénalité plus importante parce que celle
proposée par le gouvernement ne permet
pas véritablement d'inciter les
entreprises à un réel changement de
pratique au lieu d'un pour cent cette
pénalité devrait être de 3% si une
entreprise de 250 salariés ou plus
n'atteint pas le seuil d'emploi de
Senior après une année enfin pour les
entreprises de plus de 5000 salariés et
un chiffre d'affaires de plus de
1500 millions d'euros notre amendement
propose une pénalité d'au moins 7% des
rémunérations et des gains merci alors
deuxième amendements identiques le 2014
monsieur Hainaut oui merci madame la
Présidente vous avez compris au fil des
discussions notre attachement dialogue
social au paritarisme suivant le modèle
drainant en règle générale mais plus
spécifiquement pour cette index senior
et donc cet amendement prévoit une
incitation et même une forme
d'obligation de négociation notamment
pour les entreprises qui auraient un
index senior dégradé pendant trois
années cette amendement j'ajoute et
cohérent avec les dispositions de
l'article 2 du projet de loi qui modifie
les dispositions supplétives relatives à
la négociation obligatoire sur la
gestion des emplois et des parcours
professionnels pour toujours dans ce
thème de négociation l'emploi des
seniors et l'amélioration de leurs
conditions de travail si l'entreprise
n'a pas respecté cette obligation alors
une pénalité de même nature que celle
déjà prévue en l'absence de publication
des indicateurs pour à lui être appliqué
un décret devra bien sûr déterminer les
conditions d'application des 7
obligation en particulier les modalités
d'évaluation de l'absence de progression
ou de la détérioration évoquée
précédemment tel est l'objet de cet
amendement je vous remercie merci le
3390 monsieur le Président Patricia
un homme la présidente de notre
amendement est similaire à celui de
Monsieur Hainaut vous avez compris que
le débattons depuis plusieurs heures au
sujet de cette indique senior dont nous
pensons qu'il est une avancée et qu'il
permettra de combler le déficit que nous
avons par rapport à nos voisins
européens concernant l'employabilité des
seniors j'ai entendu vos craintes
j'espère que cet amendement
pourra répondre partiellement à cette
difficulté et c'est un moment il y a
deux choses premièrement c'était d'être
dit une obligation de négociation d'un
accord ou d'adoption d'un plan d'action
par l'entreprise en cas d'absence de
progression ou détérioration des
brutales index et ensuite une pénalité
renforcer la portée de l'index des
seigneurs pour s'assurer qu'il soit un
outil efficace pour améliorer
concrètement l'emploi des salariés plus
âgés et donc au coeur de l'amendement
que nous portons ensemble je vous
remercie
merci de 2793 de même Lubin monsieur
Kerrouche
défendu merci le 4224 madame gréaume
merci madame la Présidente pour les
défenseurs de cette réforme on entend
souvent qu'il est question de justice
sociale que ce soit dans la suppression
des régimes spéciaux ou encore dans
l'instauration de l'index senior pour
leur garantir un emploi très bien dont
acte vous vous empresserez donc
d'adopter notre amendement qui vise à
sanctionner les entreprises pour non
respect des indicateurs du fait de
l'obtention d'un score inférieur à un
certain niveau nous vous proposons pour
les entreprises qui ne répondent pas aux
objets aux objectifs chiffrés à
atteindre en matière d'amélioration des
conditions d'emploi supplémentaires que
celles-ci soit redevable d'un montant au
moins égal à 5% des rémunérations
versées aux travailleurs de l'entreprise
chers collègue être exigeant en matière
d'égalité professionnelle notamment en
ce qui concerne les écarts de
rémunération constituent un enjeu
républicain sanctionner les grands
groupes du CAC 40 pour les rémunérations
gargantuesque versée à certains de leurs
dirigeants c'est être animé par le sens
de l'utilité public exiger une politique
féministe visant réduire les inégalités
homme-femmes c'est être animé par la
deuxième valeur qui constitue notre
devise républicaine l'égalité il est
donc temps de sanctionner véritablement
les entreprises qui n'appliqueraient pas
strictement l'égalité salariale merci
merci le 179 monsieur Milon défendu
merci le 2792 monsieur Kerrouche
présidente la perspective c'est bien sûr
de faire en sorte que cette index
Seigneur dans nos discutons depuis
plusieurs heures maintenant soit quelque
chose qui soit réellement applicable et
qu'il est une portée qui soit tout à
fait réelle et donc l'amendement que
nous vous présentons vise à faire en
sorte que nous puissions appliquer une
amende en cas de non-respect
d'indicateurs sur la qualité de l'emploi
des seniors
en effet ce n'est pas à partir de 50 ans
que va se construire une politique de
maintien dans l'emploi des salariés âgés
mais celle-ci doit s'inscrire dans un
continuum tout au long de la carrière
professionnelle dans une logique de
formation tout au long de la vie et on
s'inspire ici
des mesures dont on sait qu'elles
existent dans d'autres dans d'autres
pays européens la perspective est donc
avec cet amendement d'amorcer une
culture de la politique patronale du
vieillissement en emploi merci 4228
madame la présente assassin
il est défendu
madame a poursu poli
man
oui cher collègue c'est un amendement de
repli comme vous avez pu le l'entendre
notre groupe propose qui est des
sanctions et financières effectives pas
simplement pour la publication mais pour
le niveau des objectifs atteints nous
avions proposé de remplacer le taux de
1% par un taux de 5% et de de que ce
taux la pénalité soit fixée à 5% de la
masse salariale pour les entreprises de
moins de 1000 salariés 3% pour celle
d'au moins 300 salariés et entre 300 et
1000 et 1% pour celle de moins de 50
l'amendement de repli c'est dire à
minima il faudrait que tout le monde
paye le 1%. nous assistons aussi par la
formule de l'amendement sur la nécessité
qui soit explicitement formulée les
actions d'insertion professionnelle de
formation tout au long de de
reconversion que les organismes que les
entreprises devraient engager pour
garantir la l'embauche des seniors je
rappelle que selon le niveau de diplôme
selon la nature des emplois les fameuses
salariés en zone grise dont nous avons
plusieurs fois parlé elle considérable
chez les ouvriers
massivement il y a la zone grise et les
massivement remplis d'ouvriers
évidemment parfois de cadre et en tout
cas massivement par des non diplômés
alors même qu'évidemment l'emploi du
Seigneur diplômé est un peu meilleur
d'où la nécessité dans d'avoir des
actions de reconversion le plus tôt
possible pour celles et ceux qui
pourraient le faire reste que la
meilleure solution c'est de ne pas aller
à
64 ans gommage de légal de retraite
merci le 2486 monsieur Breuillet
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues c'est à
nouveau un amendement de mon collègue
Thomas dessus que je vous présente
depuis cet après-midi nous discutons de
cette index senior et pour l'essentiel
il est entièrement à construire il est à
construire je me permets de le dire
d'ailleurs comme l'ont évoqué les
groupes du centre et de la majorité
gouvernementale dans le dialogue social
avec les partenaires c'est de notre
point de vue une priorité la deuxième
priorité c'est qu'il soit limité aux
gens qui sont actuellement déjà
concernés par la zone grise que vient
d'évoquer ma collègue Marie-Noëlle
linman et pas étendu à 64 ans ce qui
précipiterait encore dans la difficulté
des des dizaines et des dizaines de
milliers de seniors c'est pourquoi c'est
amendement vise à rendre effective une
sanction administrative en cas de
non-respect de la publication
des indicateurs relatifs à l'emploi des
seniors sans mesure forte pour l'emploi
des seniors la réforme des retraites
condamnent les salariés de plus de 50
ans un grand nombre d'entre eux tout du
moins assombré dans la précarité une
personne sur trois n'est déjà ni en
emploi ni à la retraite et la majorité
d'entre elles en situation d'invalidité
de RSA ou de chômage sont dans une
grande précarité si ces chiffres
s'aggravent ce serait une vraie rupture
générationnelle c'est la raison pour
laquelle cette index senior peut
présenter une entrée même si c'est une
mesure largement insuffisante pourquoi
dès lors ne pas proposer un dispositif
ambitieux à la hauteur des enjeux plutôt
qu'un index non contraignant la réponse
est simple le gouvernement se limite à
ça pour répondre aux demandes du Medef
et bien nous nous demandons là où le
texte ne prévoit qu'une sanction pour
non publication des indicateurs que ça
puisse être appliqués automatiquement
par une autorité administrative
de amendements identiques le 3741
monsieur ferrique
si madame la Présidente que se
passe-t-il chers collègues pour les
entreprises qui manqueraient à
l'obligation de publication des
indicateurs de l'index senior et bien en
l'état actuel du projet de loi il est
dit qu'elles peuvent qu'elles peuvent se
voir appliquer une pénalité alors cet
amendement du groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire propose de
supprimer ce verbe pouvoir afin de faire
en sorte que cette potentialité devienne
une automaticité merci de 42009 Dieu
Julias merci Madame la prison mes chers
collègues m'ont mon collègue vient de
présenter cet amendement j'aimerais
juste rajouter quelque chose il peut pas
y avoir de d'obligation sans un régime
de sanction sinon on neutralise le
caractère obligatoire de la mesure donc
comme notre collègue nous proposons
d'instaurer une forme d'automatisation
des pénalités qui sont appliquées en cas
de non publication de l'index merci
madame le Président merci le 2791 même
Poumirol
merci madame la Présidente c'est
tellement de bain vise aussi ce index
a publié et c'est une modification des
aliments
en remplaçant le taux de 1% par un taux
à 10% en cas de non publication de ce
plafond et on fixe en même temps un
plafondable en fonction de la taille des
entreprises 10% pour l'entreprise de
supérieur à 1000 salariés 5% pour ceux
qui sont entre 300 et 1000 et 1% pour
l'entreprise de moins 50 salariés
jusqu'à 300 jusqu'à 300 salariés ceci
pour bien te dire comme la différence
des tailles des entreprises puisqu'on
sait bien que ce sont pas les TPE PME
qui font ce type de
de manque d'emploi des seniors mais
essentiellement les très grandes
entreprises donc c'est pour les
pénaliser davantage merci le 2788
en quelque sorte et propose un repli la
perspective n'est pas de faire en sorte
qu'il faille sanctionner les entreprises
mais simplement que la mesure puisse
être effective dans les faits et pour ce
faire nous proposons que le plafond de
l'amende en cas de non publication de
l'indicateur puisse être relevé à 10% de
la masse salariale tel que proposer dans
l'article 2 et le faire varier
proportionnellement à la taille de
l'entreprise pourquoi le faire varier
proportionnellement la taille de
l'entreprise parce que d'expérience on
voit très bien que les plus grandes
entreprises ont celles qui retiennent le
moi entre guillemets leur salarié les
plus âgés d'où la perspective de cet
amendement
si le 2790 monsieur Fichet
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre c'est amendement du groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicains
visent à relever le plafond de l'amende
en cas de non-publication de
l'indicateur à 5% de la masse salariale
tel que proposer dans l'article 2 tout
en fixant dans la loi un taux évolutif
proportionnellement à la taille de
l'entreprise l'objectif est que les
grandes entreprises qui gardent beaucoup
moins leurs salariés âgés et emploie que
les TPE ou PME se voient appliqués un
taux majoré en cas de non publication
sur merci merci le 2789 même
de repli qui fixent
l'amande en cas de non publication de
l'indicateur à 5% de la masse salariale
il a déjà été largement défendu donc je
n'en dirai pas plus merci merci le 3745
monsieur vernique
et merci Madame président de vous
motorisez à faire les trois suivants
donc quatre d'un coup je vais essayer
je vais essayer de pas être trop long
donc il s'agit toujours de ce fameux
taux de pénalité en fonction de la masse
salariale donc c'est 4 amendements vous
propose au choix 4 taux maximum possible
de pénalité
maximum mais quand même plus réduit que
ce que propose d'autres amendements
puisqu'ils se ventils entre 1 et 3% de
la masse salariale si beaucoup le 1948
madame Monnier
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
ministre mes chers collègues l'index
senior est suffisant est insuffisant par
rapport aux enjolies à l'emploi des
seniors mais il constitue un premier
indicateur pour améliorer les pratiques
des entreprises dans ce domaine
afin de renforcer l'effectivité de cette
disposition le présent amendement
propose différencier et rendre des
sanctions plus dissuasives pour les
entreprises de 300 salariés au moins ne
respectant pas l'obligation de mise en
oeuvre de cette index il est indéniable
que les grandes entreprises disposent
davantage de ressources que les petites
et moyennes entreprises pour produire
les données nécessaires dans le
calendrier fixé dans une logique
incitative d'équité et à ce titre
portant de prendre en compte ce
paramètre dans la détermination du
niveau de sanction pour conclure je
souhaiterais évoquer un chiffre et si tu
es un témoignage qui souligne la
vulnérabilité de nos seigneurs vis-à-vis
du marché du travail une étude récente
de l'unédique souligne que le report de
l'âge légal conduit une augmentation du
chômage des seniors avec une hausse
entre 2010 et 2022 de 5000 allocataires
de plus de 60 ans et puis je
souhaiterais citer l'exemple de Michel
58 ans qui témoignait récemment par voie
de presse ingénieur de formation il a
perdu en 2020 son travail de 4 dans une
entreprise de télécom ce qui la conduit
après avoir enfin envoyer une centaine
de candidatures à accepter un travail
peu qualifié et six fois moins rémunéré
que son dernier poste je crois que ces
mots doivent nous interpeller et nous
pousser à nous montrer à la hauteur de
l'enjeu c'est très compliqué moralement
dit-il de voir que le marché du travail
n'est pas du tout intéressé par vous on
a l'impression de ne plus exister merci
le 222 n'est pas soutenu le 2794 même
Lubin oui on fait par cette amendement
nous entendons assurer le rôle des
partenaires sociaux dans la définition
des sanctions applicables aux
entreprises sur l'index des salariés dit
senior il vise ainsi à ce que le décret
sur les sanctions soient pris après
accord des organisations syndicales et
patronales
merci
alors le 4551 n'est pas défendu le 4243
même
c'est un amendement de repli madame la
Présidente qui supprime la phrase qui
est pour nous ou très floue qui consiste
à moduler le montant de la pénalité afin
qu'elle tienne compte des efforts
constatés dans l'entreprise en matière
d'emploi des seniors ainsi que des
motifs pardon de mes connaissances de
l'obligation de publication nous vous
l'avons déjà dit mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre la pénalité est
extrêmement faible et ne porte que sur
la non publication de l'index senior 1%
des rémunérations et gains et en plus là
il faudrait que celle-ci puisse être
moduler ça ne nous semble absolument pas
sérieux je voudrais citer Catherine
Perec secrétaire confédéral de la CGT
qui est en charge des retraites et qui
explique que les entreprises cite n'ont
pas envie et pas besoin de garder les
seniors très longtemps soit parce qu'il
coûte trop cher soit parce qu'ils ne
sont pas jugés à ces productifs je pense
qu'il faut que nous méditons sur cette
phrase d'une responsable syndicale donc
le sens de notre amende ment c'est qu'il
faut être sérieux ne pas céder aux
sirènes du Medef voilà merci alors deux
amendements identiques le 2795 même Luc
band
même même le héros
oui c'est un amendement qui ont en fixé
la pénalité sur des critères directement
liés à la situation de l'emploi les
salariés de plus de 50 ans dans les
entreprises et non à la publication
d'une mesure il vise pour se faire à
fixer le menton de l'axe le montant de
la sanction en fonction de l'écart
constaté entre la situation d'emploi et
d'embauche des salariés âgés de 50 ans
et plus et l'objectif chiffré
d'amélioration des conditions d'emplois
et d'embauche de ces salariés merci le
donc je pense qu'il faut être honnête
l'index senior c'est en quelque sorte la
mesure phare de la première partie de
cette réforme celle sur laquelle en
quelque sorte tout repose si le
gouvernement ne parvenait pas à résorber
le chômage des seigneurs dans ce pays la
note en matière d'allocations chômage et
de RSA risque c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire d'être salé et le prétexte
économique qui aura initialement motivé
cette réforme risque d'être mal compris
par nos concitoyens l'espèce il vous
sera difficile monsieur le ministre de
le mettre sur le dos d'un manque de
pédagogie c'est pourquoi nous nous
attendions à ce que vous ayez
appris de l'échec de votre autre index
portant sur l'égalité professionnelle ce
type de dispositif c'est une usine à gaz
sans aucune garantie de transparence et
sans garantie d'efficacité déjà que les
pénalités financières sont largement
théoriques concernant l'index d'égalité
homme-femme puisque seulement 32 ont été
prononcés depuis sa création mais et
c'est le sens de cet amendement on le
sait le futur index senior sera encore
moins coercitif que l'index égalité
puisque seul sera sanctionné l'absence
de publication en cas de mauvais
résultats l'entreprise sera simplement
tenue à une obligation de négociation
renforcée je voudrais dire ce que c'est
quand même le comble les sanctions ne
s'appliqueraient non pas aux entreprises
qui ont de mauvais résultats mais
seulement à celles qui refuser aient de
le reconnaître je pense monsieur le
ministre qui serait impératif que les
entreprises soient sanctionnées selon
les chiffres les objectifs chiffrés de
maintien dans l'emploi et le cas échéant
d'embauche de personnes relevant de
l'index merci le 2322 monsieur
gremillier
a pour but tout simplement de dire que
la proposition retenue par un
gouvernement n'est pas adapté à l'enjeu
majeur que celui de l'emploi des seniors
et l'amendement qui nous proposons et en
conséquence est de limiter le dispositif
de sanction ou seul défaut depuis
l'application de l'emploi des seniors à
l'exclusion de toute appréciation
qualitative des efforts de l'entreprise
en la matière
merci 4155
outils d'objectivation de la place des
travailleurs et des travailleurs seniors
dans l'entreprise possède la seule vertu
d’être utile à la statistique et encore
puisqu'il devrait procéder partout de la
même construction des indicateurs nous
constons cette manière d'avancer alors
même que vous n'êtes pas à voir de
bouscurie quand il est question de
repousser l'âge de la retraite les
salariés seigneurs de plus de 60 ans
devraient être de jeunes retraités voilà
notre position nous mettons donc en
place un seuil d'exigence défini par
décret en dessous duquel les entreprises
auraient un délai de mise en conformité
et ce délai dépassé elle se verrait
appliquer une pénalité financière merci
merci alors le 2797 madame
oui c'est un amendement qui vise à
introduire des pénalités financières
envers les entreprises qui ont des
pratiques discriminatoires en matière
d'emploi des seniors et de faire varier
son montant en fonction de la taille des
entreprises concernées en particulier en
cas de pratique discriminatoire les
entreprises seraient relevables d'une
pénalité dans la limite de 5 % des
rémunérations et des gains le taux de
cette pénalité varie proportionnellement
selon la taille de l'entreprise et le
produit de la pénalité
financière
serait affecter à la caisse
mentionnée à l'article l22-1 du code de
la sécurité sociale et si vous me
permettez pour aller plus vite je vais
défendre le suivant qui est 796 qui est
le 2796 rectifiées et qui est un
amendement de repli sans variation du
taux fixé à 5% mais avec une variation
selon la taille de l'entreprise merci
merci beaucoup et donc
identique au 2796 nous avons le 4244
défendus par Madame linman
oui il s'agit de mettre en oeuvre une
pénalité pour dans les cas de
discrimination en matière d'emploi des
seniors cette pénalité serait de 5% des
de la masse salariale
cette affaire de la discrimination des
seniors dans l'entreprise ou à l'accès à
l'emploi et particulièrement alarmant de
notre pays je vous cite la revue
retraite et société il semble qu'en
France et comportements discrimination à
l'encontre de l'âge bien qu’ilégo soit
relativement mieux toléré et moins
sanctionné que chez nos voisins
européens ainsi l'Observatoire des
discriminations constataient lors de son
étude récente que 8% encore des offres
d'emploi des commerciaux comportés en
toute légalité un critère d'âge
c'est illégal mais ce n'est pas
sanctionné les pratiques discriminantes
au travail méritent toute notre
attention et notre fermeté d'autant plus
que dans bien des cas les critères qui
cumulent on a évidemment les femmes
âgées les jeunes handicapés par exemple
sont particulièrement touchés par ces
discriminations l'enquête
Ipsos réalisée par l'association à
compétences égales relèvent que 25% des
candidatures seniors proposés par un
recruteur ont été écartés en raison
seulement de l'âge cette enquête a été
publiée en septembre 2022 selon une
comparaison internationale menée en 2021
la France se classe au 61e rang sur 68
pays en matière de de discrimination par
l'âge alors il est urgentissime de
modifier ses comportements on peut
d'ailleurs s'étonner que le patronat
soit sipron à nous dire qu'il faut
allonger la durée de travail et la
cigale de la retraite pour lui-même
travail merci le 3126 même pour c'est
mon
merci madame la Présidente alors là je
crois que c'est important je vous je
voudrais proposer de réaffecter le
produit de la sanction si on arrive à
faire des sanctions parce que je vois
que même simplement l'évocations fait
peur à notre droite donc le produit de
la sanction en code non publication de
l'index au fond de réserves des
fonds de réserve pour les retraites je
crois que c'est important de ne pas le
donner à la CNAV qui doit elle avoir des
mesures pérennes et en respectant le
lien entre cotisations et prestations et
vous verrez que nous avons des
propositions et d'affecter tout ce qui
est exceptionnel au fond de réserves
pour les retraites et là aussi nous
avons d'autres propositions que les
effectivement le produit des sanctions
donc ce qui est pérenne à la CNAV avec
des mesures pérennes et durables ce qui
est exceptionnel au fond de ressources
des réserves enfin fonds de réserve dont
effectivement qui doit être alimenté par
des ressources exceptionnelles alors bon
je rappelle quand même que en 2010 quand
il est décidé par la droite de repousser
de 2 ans de 60 à 62 ans l'âge comme par
hasard de façon
corrélée et bien au stop l'alimentation
du fond de réserve pour les retraites
qui devait effectivement nous permettent
de de traverser la bosse démographique
ou tout incident comme le covid qu'on
l'alimente pas et non seulement ça qu'on
le vide donc là je vous propose que ce
produit que j'espère exceptionnel de la
sanction pour non-respect de publication
de l'index al au fond de réserve le fond
de réserve pour les retraites
voilà
merci le 2297 madame boulesperronnier
merci madame la Présidente si nous
partageons l'objectif d'amélioration du
taux d'emploi des seniors la mise en
place de l'index senior présente dans le
secteur sportif professionnel un écueil
majeur tout d'abord en raison de la
spécificité même des contrats de travail
qui dans le sport professionnel sont des
contrats à durée déterminée spécifique
puis en raison des carrières sportives
professionnelles particulièrement
courtes en moyenne inférieurs à 7 ans et
pouvant également être stoppée
brutalement suite à une blessure orgage
au regard de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite je rappelle que les sportifs
joueurs et entraîneurs ne peuvent pas
tous bénéficier d'un reclassement sur
des postes administratifs internes pour
pallier cet état de fait il existe dans
les différentes disciplines
professionnelles des mécanismes
d'indemnisation et d'accompagnement à la
formation en vue d'une reconversion
professionnelle à la lumière de ces
éléments et en dépit des efforts
déployés par les milieu sportive
professionnelle la mise en place d'un
index senior n'est pas adaptée à la
spécificité du sport professionnel par
ailleurs si ça index devait évolué dans
les mêmes conditions que l'index égalité
salariale avec une note minimale à
atteindre à une pénalité afférente les
structures sportives professionnelles
seraient inévitablement redevable de
cette pénalité le présente amendement
propose donc que cette index s'applique
aux structures sportives
professionnelles uniquement sur la
population dite administrative en
excluant expressément les sportifs
joueurs et entraîneurs de son périmètre
d'appréciation merci
2798 même briquet
oui merci madame la Présidente c'est
amendement du du groupe service à
conditionner les dispositifs généraux
d'exonération de cotisations au respect
de l'obligation de publication de
l'index seniors telles que prévu par ce
belfsr
c'est un c'est un minimum que les
entreprises non vertueuses qui qui
pratiquent l'agisme en matière de RH
soit exclue du bénéfice des exonérations
de cotisations qui pèse lourdement sur
les recettes de notre protection sociale
ce n'est pas le tout de créer un outil
de mesure si celui-ci ne sert qu'à un
constat sans conséquence
alors le 3746 monsieur ferrique
sans réelle mesure dissuasive pour
changer le comportement des entreprises
il n'y aura guère de bénéfice pour
l'emploi des seniors or à ce stade seul
une sanction en cas de non publication
et prévue pouvant aller tout le monde
l'a compris jusqu'à 1% de la masse
salariale le dispositif doit être durci
c'est ce que propose cet amendement et
donc assurer une sanction plus
dissuasive pour les entreprises encore
en cas de non-respects de ces
dispositions conditionné le bénéfice des
éventuels réductions de cotisations au
respect de l'obligation de publication
d'index senior irait dans ce sens
si le
27 madame la Présidente cet amendement
vise à supprimer la réduction de 1,8
points du taux de cotisation
d'allocations familiales aux
rémunérations comprises entre 2,5 et 3,5
SMIC pour les entreprises qui ne
joueraient pas le jeu de l'emploi des
seniors cette disposition est d'autant
plus juste que l'efficience de telle
réduction de cotisations à ces niveaux
de salaire est loin d'être avéré et
grève les comptes de notre protection
sociale je remercie merci le 2802 madame
le héros
oui non donc nous proposons de
de faire de l'emploi des seniors et de
l'amélioration de leurs conditions de
travail un sujet de dialogue social dans
les négociations annuelles obligatoires
qui s'appliquent à toutes les
entreprises quelle que soit leur taille
à l'instinct à l'instar de l'égalité
professionnelle merci si le 3175 va même
penser mon
si vous voulez vous défendez les deux
amendements
alors cet amendement est inspiré d'une
organisation syndicale d'une femme et je
pense qu'elle sera aussi soutenue par
les autres organisations syndicales
c'est pour la fin d'agir pour le
maintien et le retour en emploi des
seniors il est nécessaire effectivement
de renforcer le dialogue social dans les
entreprises en fait d'abord on
interentreprises dans les entreprises
les branches professionnelles cet
amendement a donc comme vocation à
rendre obligatoire la négociation au
moins une fois tous les trois ans dans
les entreprises où sont constituées une
ou plusieurs sections syndicales
d'organisation représentative autour de
la situation d'emploi des seniors en cas
d'échec de la négociation l'employeur
est quand même tenu de proposer de
mettre en place un plan d'action destiné
à assurer l'emploi et les bonnes
conditions de travail des salariés âgés
ainsi que effectivement la transmission
des savoirs et des compétences je pense
que les personnes âgées sont très
demanderai de de transmettre afin de
favoriser donc l'emploi et la bonne la
bonne utilisation si ce mot des
travailleurs âgés dans le cas où aucun
accord n'est signé et où l'employeur n'a
pas rédigé de plan d'action alors là à
l'entreprise pourra être sanctionné
financièrement ainsi les entreprises ne
participant pas à l'effort soit en
embauchant soit en gardant les seniors
doivent proposer un plan d'action c'est
l'objet de cet amendement afin de
permettre effectivement
le meilleur la meilleure emploi des
travailleurs âgés
et si les indicateurs sont mauvais
entreprises doivent en effet rectifier
la trajectoire qui est la sienne en taux
d'emploi des seniors si elle ne répond
pas à un objectif qui a été fixé par le
plan d'action voilà c'est le sens de
cette amendement je vous remercie
vous conserver la parole madame ponce
pour le 3469
les défendus
on va pas attendre
merci madame la Présidente
alors sur le constat qu'il est
aujourd'hui
crucial d'actionner tous les leviers
nécessaires pour améliorer l'emploi et
les conditions de travail des seniors
il est proposé
cette un alinéa rédigé en ce sens il
existe en effet cela a été dit de fortes
discriminations à l'encontre des
salariés âgés dont beaucoup de fait sont
aujourd'hui exclus du marché du travail
et dans un tunnel ce qu'on a appelé plus
exactement un sas de précarité jusqu'à
l'âge légal de la retraite et qui sera
donc différé de deux ans on le rappelle
on le dira jamais à 16 63% des salariés
âgés de 44 à 55 ans en recherche
d'emploi non pas été sollicités par des
recruteurs au cours des 6 derniers mois
contre 26% chez les 18 34 ans ce qui est
effectivement la preuve un indicateur
d'une discrimination par l'âge ces
disparités fortes impliquent donc
nécessairement un renforcement des
dispositifs de négociations internes aux
entreprises afin de lutter ce qu'on
appelle contre la Gys la discrimination
par l'âge dans le monde du travail
donc le président amendement visage
ainsi d'inclure pleinement les questions
de l'amélioration des perspectives
d'évolution professionnelle des
opportunités de formation de la qualité
de vie au travail une réflexion sur les
conditions de travail de l'emploi et du
maintien en emploi des seniors dans le
cadre de ces négociations internes que
nous rendons donc obligatoire je vous
remercie merci le 2800 même Lubin
madame Lubin est debout non moi c'est le
1 2801 ah d'accord donc le 2800 est
défendu de 1800 à Madame Lubin donc
c'était une amendement qui vise à faire
de l'emploi des salariés âgés de plus de
50 ans un sujet obligatoire de
négociation sur la gestion des emplois
et des parcours professionnels et sur la
mixité des métiers dans les entreprises
d'au moins 50 salariés
merci
le 2803
c'est un homme en demande qui visait
associé étroitement les organisations
syndicales et patronales dans le cadre
de l'ensemble des dispositions que le
gouvernement prévoit de prendre par des
craies dans un objectif de
revitalisation de la démocratie sociale
largement malmenée tout au long du
premier quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron et
encore maintenant malgré les promesses
d'ouverture et de dialogue qui devaient
voir advenir
un martyanisme nouveau
ouais merci
Madame Lubin le 4248
identique
alors
même la présentation
qui avez-vous désigné madame a poursu
poli qui est dans le couloir là
[Rires]
merci madame la Présidente cet
amendement spécifique que les
organisations syndicales sont associées
à la définition des indicateurs et des
objectifs chiffrés dans le but
d'améliorer les conditions d'emplois et
d'embauche de plus de 50 ans cet
amendement assure tout le mérite de
rappeler que les organisateurs aussi ont
syndicales auraient dû être sollicité
avant de dépôt du texte le débat
parlementaire aurait tranché ses
négociations préalables nos travaux
auraient affinés le contenu de l'index
senior tout au contraire le gouvernement
a réussi à mobiliser contre lui et
contre son projet une haters syndicale
unie dans la lutte pour le retrait de
cette contre-réforme le gouvernement de
son côté revendique qu'une négociation
qui a lieu depuis plus de trois années
des discours certes mais qui portaient
sur un régime par point donc sans aucun
point commun avec la réforme
paramétrique en discussion des
discussions certes mais des syndicats
alerter encore le 28 novembre dernier et
se disait prêt à entamer un véritable
bras de fer salvateur pour les
travailleurs et les travailleuses
Philippe Martinez avertissait clairement
cela présume de puissantes mobilisation
si le gouvernement persiste Laurent
Berger de son côté disait est-ce que le
gouvernement a vraiment envie de mettre
le feu au pays et est-ce qu'il a envie
de faire une réforme profondément
injuste pour les travailleurs les plus
modestes monsieur le ministre
pensez-vous que l'on peut avoir raison
contre toute et tous une chose est
certaine tout seul vous n'avez pas
réussi à proposer un dispositif
utile et abouti pour préserver l'emploi
des seniors vous renvoyez un décret avec
des concertations nous vous disons qu'il
ne fallait pas décrire mais dès
concertations monsieur le ministre on
négocie pas une fois que l'on a fait
payer en l'espèce le monde du travail de
deux années de labeur supplémentaires
merci alors le 2804 même le bain alors
le terme concertation a tellement été
dévoyé depuis 2017 qu'il convient de
revenir au fondamentaux du dialogue
social à savoir la négociation cette
amendement de notre groupe viser donc à
remplacer la concertation prévue à la
ligne à 16 négociation sur la
préparation du décret fixant la liste
des indicateurs de l'index du senior et
leur méthode de calcul par une
concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux pour information
martialisme ça existe ça n'a pas grand
chose à voir avec ce que je voulais dire
je crois qu'il s'agissait de macronisme
nouveau
c'est ce que nous avions compris mais on
a pensé qu'il y avait un correcteur
automatique qui va vous avez joué un peu
un petit tour on va dire comme ça le
2805 même Lubin
même Monier non même humain
notre amendement vise à faire entrer en
vigueur l'index senior dès le premier
octobre 2023 pour toutes les entreprises
soit six mois environ après la date
prévisionnelle de promulgation de la
réforme et non au 1er novembre 2023 pour
les entreprises au moins 1000 salariés
puis au 1er juillet 2024 pour les
entreprises comptant entre 300 et 1000
salariés et enfin en premier juillet
2025 pour celles entre 50 et 300
salariés merci même pensément je prends
le 3470
oui merci madame la Présidente alors là
il s'agit d'appliquer effectivement à
compter du premier novembre 2023 les
dispositions pour les employeurs en
effet je fais remarquer que quand même
systématiquement dans toutes les lois
les réformes s'appliquent immédiatement
sur les travailleurs et toujours de
façon différée pour les pour les
employeurs
ça a été ainsi je le rappelle quand même
pour le fameux bonus malus pour rupture
de contrat court toutes les réformes ont
touché tout de suite les travailleurs à
tel point que
l'inédith dit déjà que toutes les
réformes d'assurance chômage ont fait
économiser 5 milliards sur les
travailleurs par contre le bonus malus
on n'a pas encore son retour alors là il
s'agit donc d'appliquer dès le premier
novembre 2023
parce que je viens de le dire à 61 ans à
tout pour tous ceux qui sont aux portes
de la retraite la loi va s'appliquer
immédiatement et les craintes que nous
avons et pour lesquelles on veut
justement accélérer les contraintes si
on peut appeler ça contrainte envers les
employeurs c'est qu'effectivement la
réforme de 2010 nous dit dès à présent
que le
déplacement de deux ans a bien augmenté
le taux d'activité des seniors mais ne
serait-ce que par l'effet de la noria
mais qu'elle a aussi augmenté le chômage
des seniors de 7% pour les hommes et de
6% pour les hommes les femmes pardon
comme elle a augmenté de 3% les
inactivité donc au final la réforme aura
pour effet de figer des situations en
prolongeant la durée d'emploi pour les
seigneurs déjà on emploie contre leur
état de santé et la durée d'inactivité
ou de chômage des seigneurs sans emploi
c'est stratégie qui le dit et donc il
est grand temps de d'appliquer
immédiatement quand même cette index
afin de d'accélérer les mesures
permettant d'améliorer quand même
l'emploi des seigneurs insuffisante je
vous remercie alors le 3471 madame ponce
alors c'est bon et c'est un amendement
de repli ou du moins une petite
différenciation ça vise à aussi
accélérer la mise en oeuvre de
l'obligation de publication de l'index
senior en distinguant cette fois c'est
vrai les entreprises au moins 300
salariés qui verront cette obligation
s'appliquer dès cette année parce que
vous l'avez dit elles ont tous les
éléments par le par le document de la
gpoc et par rapport à des entreprises
d'au moins de moins de 300 salariés qui
disposeront d'un délai supplémentaire
jusqu'en juillet 2024 pour mettre en
place cet outil donc le groupe
écologiste propose de faire de l'index
senior un outil réellement ambitieux
capable d'avoir un impact sur l'emploi
et la qualité de l'emploi des seniors
dans cette optique il est crucial de
tirer le son du passé et de mettre en
place un index senior suffisamment à la
hauteur des enjeux cela passe d'abord
par cette petite mesure qui est tout
simplement d'avancer la date
d'application du dit index
et cet amendement vous le remarquerez
opère toutefois la distinction entre les
entreprises de taille moyenne et les
petites entreprises en conférence à ces
dernières un temps supplémentaire
d'adaptation jusqu'au 1er juillet 2024
c'était l'objet de cet amendement je
vous remercie merci la maman 2110 de la
commission monsieur Savary j'ai le
rapporteur
merci merci
mais c'est amendement consiste mes chers
collègues à définir les modalités
d'application
contenu du fait qu'on a remodifié le
seuil il nous est arrivé à 50 on l'a
remis à 300 et en conséquence on
confirme les dates d'entrée en vigueur à
savoir le 1er novembre 2023 pour les
entreprises de plus de 1000 salariés et
le 1er juillet 2024 pour celle de plus
de 300 salariés
merci le 2018 monsieur Hainaut
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre sous a compris combien on
est attaché à la mise en oeuvre de cette
index senior dans le cadre du dialogue
social et du paritarisme et comme j'aime
bien taquiner nous croyons à la
responsabilité sociale sociétale et
environnementale des entreprises et des
entrepreneurs et donc pour nous ce cette
index senior doit se mettre en
œuvre le plus rapidement possible et
donc on propose pour les grandes
entreprises qu'ils puissent se mettre en
oeuvre dès le 1er novembre pour les
entreprises depuis plus de 5000 et
ensuite qu'il y ait de la progressivité
ce qui permettra une mise en oeuvre
rapide je vous remercie merci deux
amendements identiques le 3472 même
pensé Monge
merci madame la Présidente alors par cet
amendement considérant qu'il y a urgence
il doit y avoir urgence puisque ça
s'applique immédiatement pour les
salariés dès le 1er septembre et que les
entreprises dont moins 500 salariés
disposent déjà des outils nécessaires
pour mettre en place l'index je rappelle
que ils l'ont dans le cadre de leur
obligation de gérer de façon
prévisionnelle les emplois et les
compétences le groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire propose donc
d'appliquer l'obligation de publication
de l'index senior à ces entreprises dès
cette année au 1er novembre 2023
alors je rappelle quand même quelques
chiffres de contexte fin 2021 la
proportion des 55 64 ans qui occupait un
poste c'est levait à
56%, 3 points de moins de au-dessous de
la moyenne de l'Union européenne alors
il faut quand même matiner ça du fait
que nous notre âge légal d'ouverture
c'est 62 ans donc j'attends toujours les
statistiques 55 62 ans pour permettre
une vraie comparaison l'écart était
encore plus marqués s'agissant des 60 64
ans voilà avec un taux d'emploi de 33%
en France mais je viens d'expliquer en
partie une des raisons du fait de la
persistance de discrimination quand même
des employeurs basés sur l'âge les
seigneurs au chômage le reste plus
longtemps que les autres catégories de
la population et le reste durablement
c'est vrai que le taux de chômage des
seniors ne guère plus important leur
caractéristiques c'est que c'est du
chômage de longue durée et c'est pareil
pour la maladie ils sont pas plus
malades mais ils sont sur des arrêts
longs donc
toutes ces inégalités basées sur l'âge
considéré comme des salariés souvent
jetables du fait de leur coûts fait que
il faut effectivement accélérer les
obligations du côté des employeurs je
vous remercie merci le 4249
identiques à Monsieur zoulias
mes chers collègues nous aussi nous
souhaitons avancer la publication de
l'index au seniors au 1er novembre 2023
pour les entreprises d'au moins 500
salariés et au 1er juillet 2024 pour les
entreprises comptant entre 300 et 500
salariés pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui
30% de la gestion des ressources
humaines et déjà confié à des
prestataires extérieurs donc tout est en
place pour pouvoir déjà répondre à cette
demande et renseigner quasiment dès
aujourd'hui
l'index des seniors je vous remercie
madame merci le 2359
monsieur
le ministre chers collègues la loi pacte
en 2019 avait souhaité rationaliser
l'ensemble des seuils relatifs aux
entreprises parce que c'est vrai qu'il y
en avait une multiplicité et avait
souhaité que les seuils se rationalisés
à 11,50 et 250 c'est l'objectif de cet
amendement madame la Présidente merci
de 1946 même jasmin
merci madame la Présidente ça va dans le
droit fil de ceux qui viennent d'être
dit mais pour les outre-mer comme nous
avons beaucoup de très petites
entreprises qui n'emploie pas beaucoup
de salariés même très peu et quelques
fois une seule personne le patron donc
maintenir la possibilité qu'il y ait et
finalement des entreprises de 50
salariés concernés par ces mesures merci
l'amendement 211 de la commission chez
le rapporteur Savary
merci madame la Présidente nous
supprimons vous voyez ça nous arrive
aussi nous supprimons un aliné à
l'alinéa 18 et le présent amendement
propose donc de supprimer la demande
faite au gouvernement de remède chaque
année au Parlement un point d'étape sur
l'application du présent article nous
pensons que les indicateurs des
entreprises seront rendus public et que
les services statistiques du ministère
du Travail votre ministère monsieur le
ministre qui publie déjà des analyses
sur l'emploi des seniors pour en tenir
compte pour compléter leurs travaux
demandez un rapport chaque année sont
donc peu utiles oui monsieur le ministre
on fait confiance quand même à vos
équipes ça mérite d'être souligné
enfin rappelons que le Parlement tire de
la constitution des prérogatives de
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement et
d'évaluation des politiques publiques et
qu'il est sur déjà chaque année le
contrôle de l'application des lois en
conséquence ce point d'étape nous paraît
inutile merci le 2616 madame Lubin
nous proposons d'instaurer une
négociation annuelle sur l'emploi des
salariés de plus de 50 ans dans les
entreprises d'au moins 50 salariés bien
souvent la négociation collective se
cantonne au thème obligatoire dans les
entreprises et abordent sur tout très
peu les enjeux des conditions de travail
et plus largement de santé au travail or
ces sujets sont essentiels en matière de
maintien dans l'emploi des salariés âgés
et où en fin de carrière si on se réfère
au bilan de la direction générale du
travail sur la négociation collective en
2021 nous constatons que sur l'ensemble
des accords conclus le thème des
conditions de travail concerne seulement
7% des accords sachant que la moitié
d'entre eux traite du télétravail ces
dernières années les négociations
collectives ont été dominées par les
thématiques liées à la crise du covid-19
alors que le gouvernement a déjà été
contraint d'abandonner une première
réforme des retraites on aurait pu
s'attendre à ce qu'on toute logique il
actionne des leviers y compris en
matière de dialogue social en faveur de
l'emploi des salariés âgés avant toute
nouvelle réforme des retraites telles
n'a pas été le cas pour œuvrer en ce
sens la négociation collective sur
l'emploi des salariés âgés et des fins
de carrière doivent désormais devenir
des thèmes récurrents dans les
entreprises
merci Madame Lubin donc la vie de la
commission maintenant sur ses
amendements si monsieur le rapporteur
est un peu disponible ainsi que monsieur
le ministre c'est quand vous voulez
merci merci merci merci merci
après
48 amendements de
non mais de suppression de demande de
l'index avec une motivation
extraordinaire j'ai cru que vous n'y
teniez pas l'index
j'ai donc été surpris de revoir derrière
120 amendements
proposant effectivement compte tenu des
verdures de cet index d'en amener un peu
quelque part une amélioration et j'ai
senti que vous aviez pris à cœur
justement cette dimension tout à fait
importante pour nous entreprises
quel inventivité quel inventivité le
nombre d'indicateurs
les modalités d'application de pénalité
les organismes à consulter enfin
différentes propositions
pour lequel pour lequel je ne serai pas
favorable car voyez-vous notre
conception est différente nous pensons
que les partenaires sociaux ont un rôle
essentiel à jouer et nous faisons
confiance aux partenaires sociaux
mais
que les choses soient claires entre nous
les partenaires sociaux nous les
écoutons qu'est-ce qui nous ont dit les
partenaires sociaux
les partenaires sociaux nous ont dit
qu'ils souhaitaient que le Sénat
débattre
et que le Sénat aille jusqu'au bout du
texte
et que le Sénat est juste au bout du
texte que chacun prenne ses
responsabilités
et en conséquence quand on voit un
nombre d'amendements de suppression
après un nombre d'amendements vantant
les qualités de ce que l'on a voulu le
supprimer on peut se demander si vous
avez la même impatience pour aller
jusqu'au bout du texte
ceci
[Applaudissements]
ceci étant dit venons-en aux
commentaires
en ce qui concerne les amendements qui
modifient le seuil des entreprises
concernées vous l'avez compris la
Commission a choisi 300 je vous le
rappelle un seuil qui n'a pas été
improvisé 300 c'est le seuil ou les
entreprises n'est aussi sur la gestion
prévisionnelle des emplois c'est le
seuil qui est reconnu le qui a connu
pardon le maximum d'adhésion par rapport
à ceux que nous avons consulté et ils
ont été très nombreux
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
demanderai notamment à Olivier Hainaut
de ce rattacher à notre cause par
rapport à l'Allemand qui était très
proche de même à Monsieur Segoin de
retirer son amendement s'il en est
d'accord ou ceux qui l'ont consigné
parmi vous n'hésitez pas à le retirer
dans le même prolongement la commission
est défavorable maintenant on
modification des modalités d'application
par seuil
la Commission propose de rendre
l'article applicable au 1er novembre
2023 c'est mon amendement pour les
entreprises de plus de 1000 salariés et
au 1er juillet 2024 pour celle de plus
de 300
et nous sommes qui n'est pas préférable
de multiplier les seuils parce que bien
sûr cela nous a été proposé
et non plus les dates d'application ça
sert à rien de les échelonner ce qui
compliquerait complètement les
différents dispositifs
également des amendements d'une
redoutable importance modifier le terme
de seniors
voilà pour conserver celui plutôt de
salariés âgés
je pense que le terme de Seigneur qui a
été remis par la Assemblée nationale à
leur demande mérite d'être pris en
considération puisque c'est l'émanation
de l'Assemblée nationale
en ce qui concerne la pénalité qui
pourrait être infligée aux entreprises
qui ne publie pas leurs indicateurs
[Musique]
et sur la procédure de publicité de
prononciation de la pénalité le taux de
1% maximum de la masse salariale nous
paraît suffisant on en a déjà débattu
alors bien sûr il y en a qui voulaient
quelques
sanctions supplémentaires
par rapport à ceux qui manqueraient
leurs obligations nous ne pensons pas
que ce fut utile il ne semble pas
utile non plus de préciser dans la loi
les modalités publiques cité des
indicateurs il y en a qui préfèrent le
système électronique manuel tout ça
c'est important mais enfin on peut
penser que il y a un ministère du
Travail et qui sera organisé tout cela
de même les détails de la procédure pour
prononcer la pénalité il y a là aussi
suffisamment me semble-t-il de membres
monsieur le ministre à votre ministère
pour faire en sorte qu'ils puissent nous
proposer des choses tout à fait
intéressantes à travers des décrets il
est d'ailleurs déjà prévu que le montant
de la pénalité pourra varier selon les
efforts constatés les raisons du
manquement ce qui permet nous
semble-t-il une marge d'appréciation
tous ces éléments seront donc définis
par décret virgule après
un prêt proposition aux partenaires
sociaux et concertation
concertation monsieur le ministre au
sens de discussions et de négociation
nous souhaitons vivement que ces
concertations après la loi soit plus
productive que les concertations avant
la loi
sur les amendements qui précisent des
types d'indicateurs qui précisent leur
champ d'application ou qui exclut
certains secteurs ou professions du
champ des indicateurs
nous pensons que cela relève du dialogue
social
un décret fixera les indicateurs après
concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux puis des accords de branches
pourront les adapter par secteur ce que
nous avions déjà formulé il ne faut donc
se risquer à figer dans la loi des types
d'indicateurs ni leur modalités de
calcul ou de prise en compte des
salariés
dans le secteur du sport par exemple
madame
chère Cécile dans le secteur du sport
les branches professionnelles Céline
les branches professionnelles pourront
décider par accord que certaines
catégories ou professions sont hors du
champ des indicateurs contenus de leur
spécificité néanmoins le seuil étant de
300 je crois que toutes ces entreprises
tournaient vers le sport et nous avons
été sensibilisés par de nombreux d'ailes
également par le sénateur Savin sont en
dessous du seuil de 300 et à mon avis
elles sont déjà satisfaites du fait que
nous ayons remonté le seuil ce qui me
paraît tout à fait important pour elle
même chose également pour les
amendements qui souhaitent préciser les
objectifs à atteindre pour les
entreprises pour améliorer l'emploi des
seniors cela relève notamment aussi
la consultation des partenaires sociaux
sur les amendements qui prévoit que les
entreprises devront atteindre des
résultats à l'index des entreprises qui
souhaitent fixer des notes minimales à
atteindre qui imposent des objectifs de
procession des accords collectifs plan
d'action en cas de dégradation des
résultats l'index qui conditionnent
l'application de réduction de
cotisations respect des indicateurs qui
instituent des bonus malus de
cotisations en fonction des résultats de
l'index nous considérons que l'index
doit assurer une photographie de la
situation de l'emploi des seniors dans
l'entreprise et que sa publicité doit
être inciter les entreprises à se saisir
de cet enjeu mais qu'il ne doit en aucun
cas devenir un outil coercitif ou un
outil pour obliger les entreprises à
prendre des mesures sur la base d'un
classement ou d'une progression de leurs
résultats
les indicateurs seront variables selon
un secteurs il donneront des
informations mais ne pourrons pas
constituer un outil pour évaluer la
progression ou appliquer des sanctions
sur la base des résultats
merci de m'écouter c'est la réponse à
vos questions
nous avons proposé d'autres outils
incitatifs pour favoriser l'emploi des
seniors les sanctions ou les bonus malus
ça vient de par là ayant largement
montré leur limite par le passé
effectivement il y a déjà différentes
propositions qui ont été faites et qui
n'ont pas donné les résultats escomptés
n'ajoutons donc pas de mesure
supplémentaires qui sanctionne ou qui
oblige à prendre des plans d'action en
cas de dégradation des indicateurs sans
faciliter en amant le recrutement et le
maintien en emploi des seniors et je
pense aux amendements 2014 d'Olivier
Hainaut il a pas de chance désolé mais
on a suffisamment discuté pour que ils
comprennent bien notre proposition et
l'amendement
3390 de
monsieur lévrier
je demanderai le retrait si vous voulez
bien
ensuite sur les amendements qui précise
le champ de la négociation sur l'emploi
des seniors qui devra se faire dans le
cadre de la négociation sur la gestion
des emplois des parcours professionnels
par les entreprises de -300 salariés il
n'est pas souhaitable de trop corseter
le dialogue social dans les entreprises
devront donc aborder l'emploi des
seniors en prenant en compte les
résultats aux indicateurs laissons
ensuite les acteurs du dialogue social
se saisir du sujet selon les spécialités
de chaque secteur et de chaque
entreprise
sur les modalités de prise des décrets
d'application et de consultation des
partenaires sociaux pour mettre en place
l'index le mode opératoire nous paraît
pertinent et suffisant
concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux pour prendre le décret qui
fixera les indicateurs puis possibilité
d'adapter ses indicateurs par accord de
branche nous sommes donc défavorables
aux modifications de ce processus
proposant par exemple une négociation
préalable au décret ce qui nous semble
pas adapter
par ailleurs il n'est pas utile de
renvoyer un décret en Conseil d'État ce
qui est renvoyé dans l'article un décret
simple ni de consulter au préalable un
ensemble d'organismes ou d'institutions
tels que ça a été proposé alors que les
partenaires sociaux seront associés en
conséquence et vous l'avez peut-être
compris je mettrai un avis défavorable à
tous ces amendements en discussion
commune
et comme ils sont très nombreux sauf
ceux qui sont identiques bien entendu en
demandant le retrait notamment des
amendements 1970 2014 et
3390 je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre vous avez la
parole merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente sur cette longue série
d'amendements en discussion communes
peut-être quelques réactions
relevant plus du commentaire si je peux
me permettre que de la vie à ce stade il
a été demandé notamment par madame la
Présidente SSI par Madame Lubin de
prévoir la communication des indicateurs
de chaque entreprise au ministère du
Travail cela ne relève pas du niveau
législative mais c'est bien prévu je
l'ai dit à l'Assemblée nationale je le
répète devant vous et c'est une évidence
que ce soit prévue puisque sans
communication ministère du Travail il
n'y aurait pas de possibilité pour la
DARES de procéder à l'analyse des
données donc ce sera prévu c'est la
raison pour laquelle sur ses amendements
de 1754 de Madame assassy 4159 de Madame
Lubin c'est une demande de retrait dans
le même ordre d'idée il y avait des il y
a eu un son d'intervention interrogeant
sur l'articulation entre l'index seniors
et les questions relatives à l'égalité
femme homme c'est notamment le cas d'une
plus de parole sur l'art sur l'article
je crois de madame la sénatrice
Rossignol c'est le cas d'un amendement
de Monsieur Ferny le 3732 ainsi qu'un
amendement de Madame Vogel Vogel j'ai
peur de décrocher votre nom vos gel le
4654 un amendement Rixens est adopté
dans l'Assemblée nationale et qui
prévoit l'introduction de critères pour
l'indicateur et donc secrétaire jean-ré
permettra l'articulation avec l'index
égalité professionnelle femme homme
c'est la raison pour laquelle sur ces
amendements de 3732 et 4654 c'est une
demande de retrait de la même manière
les amendements 178 et 2947 qui ont été
présentés comme étant à l'initiative de
la Fnac relatif à la prise en compte du
nombre de licenciements pour inaptitude
ou incapacité seront aussi satisfaits
c'est un engagement que j'ai pris au
banc l'Assemblée nationale que je prends
bien volontiers devant vous c'est la
relève du décret comme d'autres
indicateurs mais je tenais à porter
cette précision et c'est vrai aussi pour
la maman 197
présenté par Monsieur nigonnet qui
concerne aussi en tout cas qui
intéressait au premier chef dame la
sénatrice voulait espérons ce qui a été
pardonnez-moi c'est ce qui a été dit par
monsieur le rapporteur est juste dans le
cadre du dialogue de bronche les clubs
sportifs qui salariés afin des
personnels administratifs et techniques
d'une part mais aussi des sportifs de
haut niveau pourront exclure les
sportifs de haut niveau de la prise en
compte de leurs effectifs pour les
calculs de l'index pour le reste sur le
seuil d'application parmi les différents
amendements déposés certains vont
modifier le seuil de la duquel l'index
est une obligation l'Assemblée nationale
avait donc adopté un abaissement du
seuil de 300 à 50 salariés et si je
partage la demande exprimée par
l'assemblée de renforcer la portée
d'index j'entends aussi la préoccupation
que cette obligation soit pleinement
opérationnelle et articulée avec
l'obligation de négociation sur la
gestion des emplois les parcours
professionnels c'est la raison pour
laquelle le gouvernement donne un avis
de sagesse à l'amendement monsieur le
rapporteur général
le manque 2109 et souhaite le retrait de
l'amendement sollicite pardon le retrait
de la demande en 1970 de Monsieur Seguin
puisque l'objectif est le même mais la
rédaction est concurrente
il y a il y en a des plus célèbres
monsieur Duplomb surtout de votre côté
mais de Monsieur sagouin pardonnez-moi
sur l'amendement déposé par Monsieur
Hainaut le 2015 c'est une demande de
retrait à moins qu'il soit parfaitement
identique à celui de Monsieur Savary je
donne aussi un avis de sagesse à la
demande 2110 de Monsieur Savary qui a
juste en conséquence la date d'entrée en
vigueur notamment la suppression de la
date d'entrée en vigueur pour les
entreprises de 50 à 3 salaires à 300
salariés si le 2109 était adopté au
titre de la coordination sur le
renforcement de l'obligation de négocier
de nombreux amendements prévoient par
ailleurs de remplacer l'emploi de
remplacer pardon l'emploi des seigneurs
au cœur du dialogue social je pense
notamment aux amendements qui instaure
une obligation formelle de négociation
sur l'emploi des seniors dans les
entreprises ou à défaut la couverture
par un plan d'action tel que les
amendements de 1802 3175 ou encore 2616
des groupes socialistes et écologistes
certains amendements proposent de
prévoir un tel dispositif à la place de
l'index date de l'adocelle index je
pense que nous pouvons aller plus loin
que ce que nous vous proposons en
mesurant la protection la progression
des entreprises sans être dans un
dispositif aussi contra donc celui qui a
été proposé en conséquence et en
cohérence avec la position exprimée par
le gouvernement à l'Assemblée nationale
je donne un avis favorable aux
amendements 2014 du groupe Union
centriste déposé par Monsieur Hainaut et
3390 du groupe RDP des creusés et
présenté par Monsieur Patriat qui
prévoit qu'à l'issue d'une première
période d'observation il y a
l'obligation d'un plan d'action pour les
entreprises qui n'auraient pas réalisé
de progrès je serai en revanche
défavorable aux autres amendements qui
introduisent les obligations purement
formelles revenant sur des obligations
qui n'ont pas fonctionné par le passé je
suis aussi défavorable aux amendements
qui institut une sanction sur le
résultat de l'index tel que le 37 39 le
46 57 ou encore le 42 17 sur les autres
propositions le gouvernement sera aussi
défavorable aux amendements qui agissent
sur le niveau de la pénalité nous
considérons que la sanction portée au
maximum à 1% de la masse salariale pour
l'ensemble des entreprises et largement
suffisante et par exemple une entreprise
d'environ 400 430 salariés avec un peu
plus de 15 millions de salariale qui
n'aurait pas respecté l'obligation sur
une année entière se verra appliquer une
pénalité de 155.000 euros alors que si
on retenait le taux de 5% proposé par
certains amendements nous serions à
775000 euros si sur un chiffre
d'affaires de 15 millions d'euros et
prohibitif je suis aussi défavorable aux
amendements qui avancent notre en
vigueur de l'entreprise de l'index pour
les entreprises de moins de 1000
salariés puisque nous considérons que
ces entreprises de 1000 salariés peuvent
mettre en oeuvre l'index dès l'année
2023 celle de moins de 1000 salariés ont
besoin d'un temps d'adaptation enfin
parce que sollicité par monsieur le
rapporteur je donne un avis de sagesse
sur l'amende 211 du rapporteur ce
rapporteur vous avez considéré que la
remise d'un rapport annuel au Parlement
pouvait être un peu redondant notamment
avec le fait qu'il est prévu et je l'ai
rappelé au début de mon propos la
transmission l'analyse par la Dares et
la publication des résultats globaux de
l'index chaque année dès lors que la
DARES est donc les services du ministère
du Travail publient les résultats et les
rendent public par essence la remise
d'un rapport serait redondant d'où la
vie de sagesse sur votre amendement
merci alors je vais mettre aux voix ces
amendements donc je demanderai oui mais
en revanche il faut me demander
la parole sur l'amendement que vous
souhaitez donc je vais donc appeler les
amendements et je regarderai qui veut
prendre la parole sur l'amendement
est-ce qu'on est on est d'accord
si vous voulez faire une seule prise de
parole moi ça ne me dérange pas non plus
à ce moment-là vous le dites voilà donc
moi je sais en premier j'ai madame
linemann qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire
vous voulez prendre la parole
globalement
sur le premier amendement donc sur l'âge
donc sur l'amendement 2613 c'est la
parole même Lindeman
ma prise de parole vise aussi à travers
le soutien à ses amendements répondre
aux argumentaires de notre rapporteur
très détaillé très intéressant
néanmoins il commence à nous expliquer
comment vous pouvez à la fois défendre
la suppression de l'indice et en même
temps après essayer de lui donner un
contenu les choses sont simples le
premier message qu'on veut faire passer
c'est que cette loi votre report à 64
ans va accroître les difficultés des
seniors et ne pas améliorer
significativement l'emploi des seniors
en France
deuxièmement que cette ex n'est pas par
ce mécanisme qui est une forme de leur
qu'on pourrait rattraper les drames qui
vont s'engager à travers vos décisions
la deuxième chose c'est que nous avons
toujours pensé que l'emploi des seniors
était réel en jeu non pas de l'emploi
contraint dans n'importe quelle
condition forcer le plus tard possible
mais parce que bien souvent les seniors
font l'objet d'éviction alors même qui
voudraient pouvoir poursuivre leur
carrière professionnelle et que notre
pays d'ailleurs n'est pas suffisamment
armé pour pouvoir favoriser les
reconversions donc il luttait de bonnes
méthodes d'avoir avec les partenaires
sociaux nos pannes concertation mais une
vraie négociation sur la manière dont le
pays améliorer l'emploi des seniors
alors la méthode que vous proposez c'est
un index nous ne croyons absolument pas
l'efficacité naturelle de cette index
mais à partir du moment où vous le
mettez en oeuvre ben on essaie de
s'attaquer à ce qu'il soit le plus
opérationnel possible même si c'est dans
un champ limité et à partir de là ça
veut dire que première chose il doit y
avoir des sanctions j'interviendrai sur
les autres amendements oui madame merci
Madame ponce
merci ma précédente moi je n'interviens
sur pas sur un amendement donc j'aurais
qu'une intervention mais à ce petit jeu
là je trouve que c'est dangereux pour
vous bien donc j'interviens sur le
général et je s'il vous plaît mais bon
je vois pas pourquoi vous m'agressez là
c'est 2 minutes vous avez deux minutes
d'intervention moi j'ai posé la question
simplement de me dire non mais
simplement de me dire même penser Monge
si vous intervenez sur l'amendement si
c'est quelque chose de plus global c'est
tout franchement
je n'aurai qu'une intervention bien
monsieur monsieur le rapporteur je suis
ça me gêne pas que vous soyez ironique
vous voyez mais ce qui me gêne c'est que
vous vous réclamiez de l'écoute des
partenaires sociaux là ça me gêne
vraiment si vous voulez parce que
respecter les partenaires sociaux ce
n'est pas mettre l'index là dans une loi
qui n'a rien à voir que vous auriez pu
mettre effectivement dans une loi
travail d'ailleurs elle certainement
sortir donc mettre l'index comme ça sans
faire de diagnostic sur les causes sans
faire de diagnostic sur le travail sans
avoir un diagnostic partagé c'est pas
respecté les les partenaires sociaux si
vous donnez un alibi un peu vers les
employeurs
respecter les partenaires sociaux oui
c'est de parler de l'article 7 les
partenaires sociaux sont très intéressés
à ce débat il nous l'aurons et qui celui
qui est le cœur de votre de votre projet
qui le porte à 64 ans l'âge d'ouverture
du droit à la retraite et ne vous
inquiétez pas nous aurons ce débat et je
crois que les partenaires sociaux sont
intéressés que par ça parce que ils nous
ils respectent notre indépendance comme
nous la leur et il nous demande rien de
particulier nous sommes des partis
politiques nous sommes autonomes c'est
la Charte d'Amiens dans l'autre sens
alors en conclusion respecter les
partenaires sociaux monsieur le
rapporteur c'est retiré cette loi avec
son index qui est qui est un peu un
détail que vous mettrez dans la loi
travail mais c'est retirer cette loi
c'est ça qui vous demande et c'est ça
que nous voulons
merci même vos gel
merci madame la Présidente je voulais
aussi répondre à quelques quelques
éléments de notre rapporteur tout
d'abord sur le fait qu'il soit surpris
par la présence de d'un certain nombre
d'amendements de retraits de lundi et de
l'index pardon et puis de tout un tas
d'amendements visant à l'améliorer
si ça le perturbe moi je lui explique
bien volontiers l'explication c'est tout
simplement que nous ne voulons pas d'un
indice qui ne servent à rien nous
voulons d'un index senior s'il sert à
quelque chose comme l'a dit Laurence
Rossignol plutôt moi je suis pas opposé
à la logique d'avoir des données je
pense et d'ailleurs c'est c'est un
élément très important notamment des
politiques féministes que d'avoir des
données parce que ça permet d'objectiver
un certain nombre de faits donc moi je
suis très ouverte à avoir à avoir des
informations mais après il faut qu'on
fasse quelque chose avec ces
informations donc la raison pour
laquelle nous avons déposé tout un tas
d'amendements pour améliorer l'index et
pour le supprimer s'il n'était pas
amélioré c'est tout simplement que nous
voulons un index qui servent à quelque
chose ou bien rien parce que autant si
ça ne sert à rien autant ne pas se
polluer la vie à faire des choses qui
sont inutiles la deuxième chose c'est
effectivement par rapport aux
partenaires sociaux coûté
voilà ayons un peu je sais pas de de
d'humilité vis-à-vis de ça moi je veux
bien qu'on dise que on se revendique de
l'écoute des partenaires sociaux sur
l'index vous savez très bien que la
demande l'unique demande de tous les
partenaires sociaux vis-à-vis de ce
texte c'est le retrait de la réforme
c'est ça que les pertes sociaux veulent
ils veulent que la réforme soit retirée
ils ne veulent pas de l'article 2
l'index des seniors ils veulent le
retrait de la réforme tout le monde je
suis désolé de m'incroyable personne ne
s'intéresse à l'index des seniors voilà
donc si vous respectez les partenaires
sociaux si vous écoutez ce qu'ils
veulent retirer la réforme c'est tout
voilà merci merci Madame gréaume
merci Madame ma présidente mon
explication de vote est sur l'amendement
cet amendement de repli vise à assurer
une obligation tribunale de négociation
au sein des branches professionnelles
portant sur
à ce moment-là la parole au moment où
votre l'amendement
si vous voulez bien
voilà d'accord
monsieur Breuillet
merci madame la Présidente j'espère ne
pas décevoir mes collègues
j'admire éblouis la grandeur des petits
je n'ai point d'autres affaires ici bac
d'aimer ces vers sont de notre illustre
prédécesseur Victor Hugo et font partie
du recueil l'art d'être grand-père alors
je veux le dire ce que je souhaite
personnellement est-ce que souhaite les
collègues de mon groupe et de la gauche
c'est que nos concitoyens puissent
encore cultiver l'art d'être grand-père
et avoir le temps pour le faire je
souhaite d'ailleurs qu'ils aient aussi
le temps de s'engager dans la vie
associative dans les conseils municipaux
dans l'aide aux parents et d'entendre
autre chose et c'est pour cette raison
que nous combattons cette loi qui
propose de leur voler deux ans j'en
viens maintenant à cet article 2 et à
l'index
je vais d'abord remercier monsieur le
ministre d'avoir donné des réponses
détaillées sur les amendements c'est pas
souvent que je le fais donc je m'y
autorise j'ai apprécié que vous
soulignez au moins en tous les cas sur
la question du genre en ce qui concerne
les amendements que de ce côté de
l'hémicycle nous avons mis qu'ils
étaient satisfaits et donc vous preniez
des engagements sur ce domaine je
m'interroge sur le compte rendu qu'a
fait monsieur le rapporteur général à la
suite de nos amendements sur cette
question de la confiance aux partenaires
sociaux il nous demande une seule chose
retirer cette réforme donc la confiance
aux partenaires sociaux et ils sont
unanimes c'est de retirer cette réforme
il reste un partenaire social qui est
effectivement ne demande pas de retrait
c'est le Medef et le Medef il demande
aussi pas de sanction financière et donc
monsieur le rapporteur je suis désolé
mais j'ai entendu au fond un soutien à
un partenaire particulier qu'elle Medef
en disant pas de sanction moi je ne suis
pas sûr que la sanction soit un outil
suffisant mais en tous les cas je sais
que le thermomètre ne suffit pas il
mesure la fièvre il mesure la difficulté
mais il ne répare pas il faut des
mesures qui réparent et qui permettent
l'emploi améliorer des seniors merci
Monsieur Lemoine
merci beaucoup Noël présidente dans le
même esprit que Marina linman et Madame
Vogel de façon un peu globale sur
l'ensemble des amendements
il était évoqué à l'instant la crainte
d'un risque de la dégradation de
l'emploi des seniors entre 60-74 ans au
regard de l'article 7 je crois que au
contraire si on a réussi à changer de
paradigme depuis les années 80
souvenez-vous les années 80 c'est l'État
qui soutenait des plans de départ en
pré-tête
pour faciliter l'entrée sur la vie du
travail sur le travail des jeunes depuis
20 ans on a réussi à augmenter de 20
points le taux justement dans l'emploi
des seniors parce que il y a un effet
horizon qui est là qui était documenté
d'ailleurs par le corps il y a une étude
de 2011 qui est très précise de Patrick
Aubert là-dessus et donc c'est pourquoi
si on regarde la situation elle s'est
améliorée de ce point de vue là
d'ailleurs il y a un taux dans l'emploi
de chômage qui qui inférieur à celle des
autres catégories même s'il faut pas
comment dire il faut être attentif
naturellement à la catégorie des dites
ner ni dans l'emploi ni à la retraite
c'est à peu près 11% il faut
naturellement des plans Haddock pour
cela mais pour le reste je crois que
l'index est un comment dire un bon outil
on a essayé la taxe souvenez-vous la
contribution de la lande ça s'est
retourné contre les seniors là
d'ailleurs été supprimé en 2008 on a
essayé le contrat de génération cher à
François Hollande la Cour des comptes a
dit en 2016 échec sur toute la ligne
40000 contrats je crois pour 250 000 qui
étaient attendus et donc on a pas essayé
l'index et l'index il a prouvé quand
même son utilité en matière d'égalité en
quatre ans regardé quand même il y a eu
des progrès la France c'était dit il y a
quelques jours et numéro un en matière
mondiale de ce point de vue là et donc
je pense que l'index senior et mais il
aura cette vertu alors il sera
perfectible d'ailleurs avec Martin
lévrier François Patriat et membre du
groupe on a proposé de l'améliorer mais
je crois que c'est un outil qui méritait
de considérer et raison pour laquelle je
ne voudrais pas l'amendement 26-13 mais
l'index dans général merci monsieur
Étienne blanc
je retire le
1970 suite aux excellentes explications
de notre rapporteur
merci
Madame
même Carlotti ça ça va ça m'a pas pris
beaucoup de temps
merci madame la Présidente
de
2753 et est-ce que c'est le moment on
les appellera oui si vous voulez bien on
essaie un peu voilà monsieur yakovelli
la mère présidente si vous le permettez
je vais faire une intervention globale
voilà juste
nous ne voterons pas la plupart des
amendements présentés à part ceux qui
ont reçu effectivement un avis favorable
de la commission et du gouvernement mais
on est un petit peu étonné après cette
multiplication de 130 amendements de
modifications qui suivent 48 amendements
de suppression d'un même index senior
index seniors qui comme on n'est pas une
incohérence près sur certains bancs de
cette hémicycle un index senior qui
pourtant est demandé à la fois par les
partenaires sociaux et puis je me
rappelle le 8 novembre dernier qui a été
présenté par notre collègue Hainaut la
création d'un index senior qui avait
bizarrement reçu l'unanimité des camps
de la gauche qui aujourd'hui demande la
suppression de ses index le Seigneur
pardonnez-moi mais là on est si c'est
pas de l'obstruction c'est bien caché
merci alors je vais mettre au bois donc
l'amendement 2613 qui est pardon vous
vouliez reprendre la parole monsieur le
rapporteur
oui merci pour amener simplement
quelques explications suite à
l'intervention de
ma collègue linman effectivement
l'emploi des seniors c'est ce qui nous
préoccupe quoi c'est la raison pour
laquelle déjà dans un premier temps nous
souhaitons que je vous le répète parce
que c'est important que ce ne soit pas
la valeur la variable d'ajustement des
entreprises c'est pour ça que je vous
rappelle on va voir on va soutenir la
proposition de monter à 30% le forfait
solaire le forfait social pour les
ruptures conventionnelles ça me paraît
un point important parce que on le voit
ça 59 ans qui se produit ça quand vous
regardez les courbes les courbes du
chômage avec les âges et vous voyez bien
que ça se pique se pique à 59 ans
d'autre part quand on fait l'analyse de
toutes ces courbes par rapport aux
réforme précédentes qui ont accru l'âge
notamment celle du passage de 60 à 62
ans on voit bien qu'il y a déjà eu un
décalage donc ça a reculé
justement cette mise au chômage de
seigneur deux ans plus tard donc il est
tout à fait légitime de penser tous les
économistes le disent que on va décaler
la borne avec l'augmentation de l'âge
alors c'est pas satisfaisant c'est pas
suffisant mais ça veut dire que le taux
de seniors et c'est pour ça qu'il est
plus important dans les pays étrangers
c'est parce qu'effectivement ils ont
déjà pris le problème avant nous ils ont
déjà décalé l'âge et ils ont fait une
politique d'emploi des seniors de prise
en compte de leur préoccupations de
faire en sorte qu'ils trouvent
l'aménagement nécessaire pour que les
seniors puis rester en emploi et c'est
comme ça qu'ils ont des taux de seniors
vous l'avez tous dit à travers vos
interventions beaucoup plus élevées que
les nôtres c'est la raison pour laquelle
on peut penser là qu'il y aura une
progression et que nous sommes tout à
fait attachés à définir cette politique
d'emploi des seniors de façon beaucoup
plus précise que ce que nous a proposé
le gouvernement et vous verrez que on
avance et j'espère qu'on va avancer
qu'on discutera non seulement de
l'article mais tous les articles qui
sont à mes yeux presque aussi importants
que l'article 7 de prise en compte
justement des différentes difficultés la
retraite progressive la prise en compte
de l'incapacité permanente des 60 ans
des marqueurs très importants d'une
réelle volonté de proposer une
amélioration sociétale par rapport à
cette tranche de vie qui a une tranche
de vie tout à fait importante et qui
prend de plus en plus de place dans la
vie de nos concitoyens merci alors je
mets aux voix donc l'amendement 2613 qui
a reçu donc un invité favorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour
qui est contre qui ça tient il n'est pas
adopté
l'amendement
madame jasmin
merci madame la Présidente j'ai entendu
les commentaires de monsieur le
rapporteur nous sommes ici pour
travailler nous sommes ici pour défendre
les Français nous sommes ici pour
défendre l'emploi donc je ne peux pas
comprendre que vous avez fait le choix
d'adopter un amendement que nous
refusions tous à gauche maintenant qu'il
a été adopté nous avions prévu en repli
évidemment des possibilités de
poursuivre parce que nous sommes nous
savons très bien que nous sommes pas
majoritaires nous avons toujours réclamé
l'implication des partenaires sociaux et
nous allons continuer à le faire mais
chaque fois que j'ai pris la parole ici
Mesdames et Messieurs mes chers
collègues j'ai toujours dit qu'il
fallait supprimer ce texte je l'ai
souvent dit et partout sur les mains de
gauche nous l'avons réclamé donc ne
faites pas croire ce que vous voulez ce
que vous interprétez il y a peut-être
des problèmes de sémantique mais à un
moment donné nous devons rester
respectueux vis-à-vis des autres merci
merci alors je mets aux voix donc
l'amendement 2614 qui est qui a reçu un
avis défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient mais donc pas adopté
l'amendement
2751 madame linman et même premier rôle
oui on est autour de ce débat sur
l'index senior mais justement
ce qu'a dit notre rapporteur mérite est
d'ailleurs de ce que Monsieur Lemoine a
dit un mérite quand même d'être pour le
moins nuancé et j'allais dire dans un
certain nombre de points contredit
oui monsieur Lemoine en effet en
allongeant de deux ans le passant de 60
à 62 ans vous avez en effet le nombre de
salariés de 60-61 ans qui ne qui sont
maintenant en activité qui a été de 20
points enfin c'est très peu au regard du
fait qu'on a donné deux ans de travail
de plus et donc mais qu'est-ce qui a été
le corollaire de ça c'est massive
augmentation de la zone grise
et en particulier chez les ouvriers dans
la même période la zone grise a augmenté
de 16 points pour les ouvriers
en 2019 à 61 ans
28% des actifs sont en emploi ça ils
activent au sens de l'INSEE et 35% ne
sont ni en retraite ni en emploi il y a
donc plus de gens en zone grise qu'en
activité en 2019 à 61 ans
et par ailleurs c'est d'une grande
inégalité puisqu'en 2021 pour la
translate 60 64 ans
25% des non diplômés ou un emploi
seulement un quart des non diplômés ont
un emploi pendant que 53% des diplômés
ont un emploi
ça creuse de manière considérable les
inégalités sociales alors si vous croyez
que c'est avec un index un index qui
n'aura même pas de sanctions que vous
allez inverser une situation qui au
contraire pas détériorée c'est à l'heure
merci Madame pounirol c'est bon
d'accord donc je mets au voile
amendement 751 qui a reçu donc un avis
défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 4126
à l'index
vous nous expliquez l'index ne doit
avoir lieu que dans les grandes
entreprises de plus de 350 salariés
or
on sait que la plupart des problèmes de
discrimination de difficultés pour les
seniors
s'opèrent justement dans des petites et
moyennes entreprises pour des raisons
pour des raisons qui peuvent être
compréhensibles c'est que la souplesse
de reconversion est souvent moindre que
dans les grandes entreprises en tout cas
en tout cas dans ces entreprises là
il y aura aucune protection sur le fait
que l'éviction des seniors qui a lieu à
égalité au moins si ce n'est plus ne
sera pas traitée vous laissez en friche
complètement cette question centrale des
petits et moyennes entreprises et en
tout cas de moins de 300 salariés ce qui
est quand même déjà des entreprises
significatives
la deuxième raison c'est il n'y a pas de
sanction
alors là c'est simple
c'est vous compter sur quoi on va mettre
des cierges on va faire des grigris on
va prendre des épingles sur des trucs
vaudou en espérant que ça marche
par quel miracle ce qui n'a pas marché
jusqu'à présent par la bonne volonté des
gens va simplement marcher parce qu'on
va soi-disant afficher un index même
dans les pays anglo-saxons ils croient
de moins en moins dans le nez man Cham
je crois que c'est ça que ça le comment
il s'appelle ça donc en réalité ça
n'aura aucune efficience et vous savez
très bien vous ne voulez ni contrainte
pour les entreprises ni efficacité ni
sanction bon franchement c'est vraiment
le doigt mouillé on espère que le vent
va tourner et ne tournera pas merci
monsieur le rapporteur
merci merci madame linman je répondrai
simplement sur vos deux interventions et
le problème effectivement qui où vous
dites où se creusent les difficultés par
rapport effectivement à la formation des
à la formation des seniors et c'est un
contestable c'est incontestable c'est la
raison pour laquelle il faut
impérativement qu'on ait un œil
différent une vision différente par
rapport au Seigneur parce que une fois
qu'on a dit ça on va pas rester les bras
croisés quand même et puis constater que
surtout que cette période est avec la
longévité elle s'étend elle s'étend il y
a une évolution aussi de
de
physiologique on le constate bien quand
même on voit bien les jeunes comme ils
sont grands par rapport à nos anciens
qui étaient un peu plus trapus donc
c'est pas la même résistance forcément
par rapport aux travaux que
connaissaient nos anciens et qui peuvent
pas être identiques aujourd'hui c'est
c'est l'évolution humaine physiologique
qui fait que on vit de plus en plus
longtemps mais peut-être avec des
fragilités différentes donc il nous faut
prendre en compte tout cela ça me paraît
d'une redoutable évidence et
actuellement et ben non tout le monde
continue à regarder ailleurs comme on
dit couramment et de ne pas prendre ça à
bras le corps c'est la raison pour
laquelle ça nous a interpellé puisque on
travaille on l'a déjà répété depuis
longtemps sur cette ce décalage de l'âge
qui ne fait qu'être une conséquence je
le rappelle l'augmentation de la durée
de cotisation que je ne conteste pas que
les choses soient claires que je ne
conteste pas
oui mais vous le contestez mais à
l'époque c'était quand même c'est quand
même mais c'est pas je veux pas rentrer
dans le secteur là mais si vous voulez
les 43 ans on les a pas inventés les 43
ans ils sont là déjà inscrits dans la
loi depuis un certain temps et en
conséquence merci en conséquence on a
cette augmentation du temps de travail
qui est logiquement c'est logique
use forcément l'individu alors c'est
pour ça qu'il faut faire attention par
rapport à ceux qui commencent de bonheur
on va voir ça avec les décalages de
bornes et avec les retraites anticipées
qui finissent un peu plus tôt c'est pas
la même endurance quand vous finissez
votre carrière à 60 ans après 43 ou 43
ans que quand vous finissez votre
carrière à 65 ans après les 43 ans
également d'activités donc il y a une
prise en compte également de la
pénibilité qui doit être adapté aux âges
voilà et en fonction de l'usure
professionnelle pour pas dire pénibilité
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai hâte
d'attaquer l'article 9 parce que c'est
là qu'on va rentrer dans le dur c'est là
qu'on va parler du concret de ce qui
peut être fait pour prendre en compte
justement cette usure peut-être
supplémentaire compte tenu de la durée
supplémentaire que l'on demande aux gens
voilà donc soyons attentif à tous et
travaillons dans le sens véritablement
d'une meilleure prise en compte de ces
seniors dans l'entreprise merci même
jasmin
merci madame la Présidente en 2017
Emmanuel Macron président de la
République et bien parmi les premières
mesures qui souhaitaient faire c'était
supprimer le Sénat
heureusement le scénar est encore là et
il a le soutien des sénateurs
pour faire passer un certain nombre de
lois mais ça ne veut pas dire que nous
qui ne sont pas forcément d'accord avec
les mesures que vous preniez que vous
adaptiez vous adoptez et bien que nous
allons rester les bras croisés ni
silencieux ni dans un mutisme bien au
contraire nous voulons reconstruire nous
sommes de la co-construction et c'est
pour cela que nous avons collectivement
travaillé pour tenter de faire quand
même notre travail de sénateur et de
sénatrice ici donc je ne souhaite pas
qu'on puisse reproduire les remarques
telles qu'elles ont été faites de ne pas
par Monsieur et non et d'autre part par
leur apporteur monsieur Savary je vous
souhaiterais que nous soyons respectueux
du travail collectif que nous faisons
ici dans l'intérêt des Français je
voudrais également dire que nous sommes
ici nous sommes sur les bancs de la
gauche mais à aucun moment nous n'avons
cessé de travailler depuis le début de
ce texte et bien nous avons travaillé
régulièrement nous avons dit ce que nous
pensions nous avons fait des amendements
vous n'êtes pas d'accord vous votez
contre c'est votre droit nous sommes
dans la quoi construction vous avez le
droit de voter pour aider nous avons
notre voie de faire aussi comme nous
voulons mais la prochaine fois j'espère
que vous allez être respectueux de nos
démarches et dans nos positions merci
Madame madame jasmin je pense que il y a
pas eu de non-respects on respecte tout
à fait en contraire chacun ses
convictions il y a pas de souci non non
ah ben non ben non on voit bien le
travail que vous que vous avez réalisé
les uns et les autres non ça y a pas de
souci s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît je vais mettre au voile
amendement 4126 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient ne peut
pas adopter
l'amendement
4655 madame Cohen
merci madame la Présidente effectivement
monsieur le rapporteur au début de son
propos a été un peu joueur il a voulu à
mon avis réveiller l'hémicycle c'est une
bonne chose à 23h30 mais je pense que
effectivement le débat nous on l'a et
nous à gauche on a depuis le début
puisqu'on s'exprime et à la fois en
critique et à la fois on fait des
propositions alternatives c'est ça la
responsabilité des parlementaires le
débat était très animé ce matin c'était
bien parce que effectivement du coup il
y a eu écho les deux côtés de
l'hémicycle et ça a été plus passionnant
effectivement parce que dans le pour
faire un dialogue il faut au moins deux
alors pour revenir pour revenir à cette
à cet amendement c'est quand même
incroyable parce que il y a
effectivement vous avez compris on est
contre au niveau du groupe CRCE on est
compte c'est très fort vous nous avez
pas convaincu c'est une mauvaise réforme
et on est contre comme la majorité des
Françaises et des Français donc à partir
du moment où on est contre on a porté
aussi des amendements où on a soutenu
des amendements pour l'indice senior qui
est un écran de fumée de l'enfumage
parce qu'il y a aucune sanction sérieuse
contre les les entreprises
contrevenantes on a porté des des
amendements de suppression ils n'ont pas
été acceptés alors nous au niveau de la
gauche qu'est-ce qu'on fait on est
constructif et le groupe communiste très
constant en plus donc on a fait des
propositions pour améliorer cet indice
qui à notre avis ne servira à rien et ne
pénalisera pas suffisamment les
entreprises qui vont être contrevenantes
et qu'est-ce que vous faites vous vous
êtes vous ne rejetez tous nos
amendements et après vous nous dites
alors franchement vous n'êtes pas
vraiment sérieux non seulement vous êtes
contre mais en plus de ça vous la
ramenez pour enrichir le texte faut
savoir mes chers collègues justement on
joue notre rôle qui est celui de
l'opposition constructive alors cet
amendement il est très important et nous
nous soutenons merci
alors je vais mettre au doigt donc
l'amendement 4655 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient n'est donc pas adopté
deux amendements
identiques le 2753 et le 4129 même car
le t
oui merci madame la Présidente moi je
voudrais dire aussi à monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez accepté l'index
senior un dispositif vide et nous ici
sur les bancs de la gauche nous tentons
de l'améliorer en fait nous faisons tout
simplement notre travail monsieur le
rapporteur en 2019 deux collègues
Martine Monique Lubin et René Paul
Savary monsieur le rapporteur s'est
épanché sur le défi des fins de carrière
ils ont fait un travail considérable qui
nous sera fort utile dans le cadre de la
loi travail qui devrait arriver que nous
sera soumises prochainement alors du
coup monsieur Savary je ne comprends pas
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec
nous pourquoi vous avez rejeté la
totalité de nos amendements même pas un
a été accepté pourtant avec Monique
Lubin vous vous disiez les mêmes choses
que ce qui s'est dit pendant ce débat
vous releviez les difficultés la dureté
de la vie des seniors dans le monde du
travail trop vite vieux pour être
recruté premier licencié dans les plans
sociaux pour pousser à partir car soumis
à des conditions de travail difficile
placardisé un seigneur sur deux n'est
plus un emploi lorsqu'il arrive à l'âge
de la retraite monsieur le ministre
voulait condamnez à deux ans de plus un
tiers vivent en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté monsieur le ministre vous ne
leur proposez rien si ce n'est allez
encore plus vers la précarité les
amendements du groupe socialiste et du
groupe communiste que je défends
développe les différentes pistes qui
devraient faire l'objet de réunion de
réflexion de travail le recrutement
l'évolution des carrières les conditions
de travail la formation le tutorat
autant de pistes qu'il faut
effectivement désormais mettre dans
cette index seniors et bien sûr la
parole au bout du bout doit rester aux
organisations syndicales patronales et
syndical et je vous demande de retirer
votre réforme afin de relancer enfin le
dialogue social dans ce pays merci c'est
le président Laurent
oui je veux redescendre cet amendement
parce que cet amendement c'était un de
ceux justement de ce que nous avons
proposé qui visait à enrichir l'index
senior parce que depuis le début notre
logique elle est très claire
contrairement à ce que vous avez dit
monsieur le rapporteur notre logique
c'est de dire que nous ne voulons pas
d'un article 2 qui soit un article alibi
pour en fait une loi qui ne comporte que
les 64 ans comme mesure sérieuses c'est
ça la vérité alors nous avons fait des
propositions à partir du moment où vous
avez vous-même accepté cet index vide de
contraintes évite d'obligation pour les
entreprises vous avez refusé tous nos
amendements en plus vous avez le culot
de dire que c'est parce que vous voulez
la négociation avec les organisations
syndicales or à chaque fois que nous
avons fait des amendements qui justement
disaient qu'il fallait que ça se fasse
avec les organisations syndicales vous
les avez rejetées aussi parce que vous
les avez tous rejetés en bloc et en
écoutez moi ce que je veux dire c'est
que vous c'est votre logique qui pose un
problème parce que vous avez décidé
d'accepter l'index senior sans le
remplir de rien du tout pour faire
plaisir au gouvernement parce que vous
avez dit les avec lui justement
l'article 7 parce que c'est pas
l'article 9 qui vous intéresse l'article
que vous attendez et l'article pour
lequel vous êtes là et pour lequel vous
me dites rien depuis le début mais vous
ne pensez qu'à ça c'est l'article 7
c'est l'article sur les 64 ans c'est ça
que vous voulez et c'est ça que vous
voulez et vous l'avez dit à plusieurs
reprises monsieur ça varie donc vous
videz l'index au seniors de tout contenu
pour faire plaisir au gouvernement vous
le garder parce qu'en vérité vous ne
pensez qu'au 64 ans et à rien d'autre
merci Monsieur Savoldelli
merci Madame la présence monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
dans la même veine de ce que vient dire
mon collègue et ami Pierre Laurent
il y a une difficulté monsieur le
rapporteur général
c'est c'est le rapporteur mais moi je
vous mets rapporteur général il y a pas
de problème
non mais si vous avez une expérience
politique d'ailleurs qui est bien plus
complète que la mienne
c'est une femme madame de roche de vous
vexez pas il y a aucune aspect personnel
enfin me faire pas perdre 40 secondes
quand même avec tout ça moi je crois que
vous avez voté en 2010 la réforme ok
madame de roche vous l'avez voté je veux
savoir où vous l'avez voté vous l'avez
voté non mais dites moi oui ou non si
c'est non c'est non mais alors mais
pourquoi je vous dis ça parce que
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé à cette époque
là on a bien rallongé deux ans
et vous êtes capable de nous faire une
démonstration aussi bien le gouvernement
que la majorité sanatoriale que ça
amélioré l'embauche et le maintien en
activité des seniors vous êtes capable
de nous donner des éléments concrets et
d'aller devant les Français les
Françaises leur dire notre réforme de
2010 en passant de 60 à 62 elle a
amélioré l'embauché le maintien de
l'activité mais vous l'avez pas ça parce
que c'est pas vrai parce que la vraie
question qui se pose avec l'index c'est
pas la question mais pour l'index vous
avez dit tout à l'heure vous avez fait
trop d'amendements etc c'est vous
reculez l'âge de la retraite ça va
prolonger la précarité des seniors il va
y avoir plus de seniors d'année sans
salaire ni pension et la question
pourquoi il y a là pourquoi il y a cette
mobilisation
depuis déjà plusieurs semaines et qui va
prendre une autre ampleur la semaine
prochaine parce que comment va tenir à
64 ans quand on n'a pas d'allocation
qu'on a ni pension de retraite et qu'on
a une maigre pension d'invalidité et là
Monsieur le Ministre dites moi si je
raconte des bêtises franchement
j'accepte la controverse est-ce qu'on
n'est pas dans une période où il y a
plus de rupture conventionnelle oui
est-ce qu'on a une période où il y a pas
plus de départ
merci voilà on est dans cette situation
là
monsieur le rapporteur va vous donner
quelques réponses
un contrat de victoire bien entendu mais
que les choses soient claires il y a pas
de Deal il y a pas de deal avec le
monsieur le mini nous ne sommes pas des
dealers vous avez votre logique nous
avons la nôtre qu'est-ce que je dis
qu'est-ce que j'ai dit en début de
discussions de cet article j'ai essayé
mais j'ai pas dû être clair d'exprimer
la logique qui avait animé la commission
pour prendre en compte effectivement cet
article 2 qui
je vous l'ai dit clairement en première
lecture me poser également des problèmes
sur cette index senior et je vous l'ai
dit il y a deux solutions soit un écart
d'un revers de main cette index et à ce
moment-là on a plus aucune possibilité
d'avoir une stratégie par rapport à
l'emploi des seniors et de la marquer
dans le cas d'un PLFSS
chez le rapporteur s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît je sais qu'il doit y avoir la
loi travail c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai au cours des auditions que
nous avons eu avec Monsieur le Ministre
j'ai demandé des engagements quant à
cette loi travail que l'on doit nous
proposer dès cette année au mois de mai
juillet il nous précisera monsieur le
ministre juin juillet calendrier
franchement je suis pas un mois près
quand même mais il est très important
parce que je le répète nous pensons
qu'il faut vraiment pour que cette
réforme soit acceptable qui a une prise
en compte de la place des seniors dans
la société à travers une loi travail
digne de ce nom nous essayons
de cranter comme on dit couramment un
certain nombre de dispositifs dès à
présent car j'ai bien une grande
confiance envers monsieur le ministre il
n'empêche que j'aime bien aussi quand on
passe aux actes voyez-vous et en
conséquent je souhaite que ce soit dans
cette loi définie dès à présent cette
stratégie en ce qui concerne les
seigneurs au chômage qu'ils puissent
cette employés à travers un nouveau CDI
qui n'a rien à voir avec le CDI actuel
puisqu'on va parler d'âge relation entre
employeur et employés ça n'existe pas
donc on essaie d'améliorer ce dispositif
c'est une logique qui nous a animé pour
les emplois qui sont enseignants c'est
la retraite progressive entre eux et
d'autres dispositifs on aura l'occasion
d'en parler c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai donné un avis défavorable
à vos amendements qui sont des
préoccupations tout à fait légitimes et
que je partage mais que je réserve dans
la discussion avec les partenaires
sociaux qui doit intervenir avant la loi
travail voyez-vous c'est le problème du
calendrier je dois pas tout définir on
doit donner une feuille de route certes
une direction au partenaires sociaux
maintenant de se positionner par rapport
à cette trajectoire
merci alors je vais mettre au bois les
amendements
oui Non Non mais il y a pas de souci je
sais je sais
j'ai trouvé moins effectivement que
monsieur le rapporteur avait l'humeur
badine
voire moqueuse parfois si un peu un peu
ça m'a d'autant plus étonné que et puis
bon oui mon cœur sur notre travail ça
m'a d'autant plus étonné que
effectivement nous avons travaillé sur
l'emploi des seniors et c'est vrai que
moi je ne comprends pas très bien non
plus pourquoi certains nombre de nos
amendements ont été
refusés alors que
ils émanent de propositions que nous
avions faites dans ce rapport voilà
alors après oui oui alors après merci de
le reconnaître alors après
pardon
vous avez seul la parole vous les
écoutez
je vais continuer voilà et donc et donc
j'ai entendu aussi que nous nous avions
des contradictions mais pas du tout pas
du tout nous ne sommes pas favorables à
cette index des seniors parce que nous
pensons que c'est un gadget et Monsieur
et Monsieur et Monsieur yakovelli un
jour on parlera de vos contradictions à
vous j'en suis pas encore arrivée au
même stade que vous alors laissez-moi
tranquille avec mes raisonnements
d'accord d'accord bon donc
merci Madame la président première fois
que je vous remettre à votre place donc
ici c'est moi qui décide oui madame la
présidente madame Hubin c'est vous qui
avez la parole monsieur yakovelli vous
ne l'avez pas merci madame la Présidente
donc nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec
des seniors aussi nous avons demandé
la suppression de cet article parce que
nous considérons que c'est un gadget et
monsieur le rapporteur lui-même a
reconnu qu'au début il était quand même
tiède voilà et derrière on se moque de
nous parce qu'on a proposé plein de
choses mais oui on a proposé plein de
choses et le débat on aurait aimé la
voir et on ne l'a pas eu parce que si
vous aviez pris le temps de regarder
quelques-uns de nos amendements je vous
assure qu'ils sont loin d'être
fantaisistes et je le rappelle sorti du
travail que nous avons fait en commun
avec le rapporteur merci merci alors je
vais mettre au bois donc ces deux
amendements de 1753 4129 qui ont réussi
un avis défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient ne sont
donc pas adoptées je vais mettre vois le
3465 madame linman
oui chers collègues j'ai bien entendu
notre rapporteur qui manifestement n'est
pas enthousiaste en réalité sur cette
index senior
et je ne comprends pas nos amis
républicains
puisque au sein même de votre partie
monsieur Pradier à l'Assemblée nationale
a expliqué ce qui me paraît pas
indépendamment des désaccords politiques
que j'ai avec lui ne me paraît pas un
fondé
puisqu'il expliquait que c'est un texte
signor n'avait rien à faire dans un
plfsr
et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que je
voudrais interroger notre apporteur pour
lui demander pourquoi il s'acharne tant
à essayer de défendre cette index senior
est-ce qu'il considère qu'il est
conforme à la Constitution
d'évoquer ce sujet alors mon oreille a
été un peu titillée par
l'assistance de Monsieur le Ministre de
nous dire que dès cette année ça allait
s'appliquer
je me suis dit autant de passion
pourquoi peut-être c'est qu'il espère
pouvoir inscrire des recettes
au titre de comment dire au titre des
pénalités pour l'année 2023 pour le
non-respect de l'index de seniors ce qui
serait une manière très comment dire un
peu trompeuse de faire croire que c'est
rattaché au bénéfaire donc j'aimerais
bien savoir Monsieur le Ministre combien
vous estimez de recettes sur
l'éventuelle taxation de la
non-application dès 2023 de cet Intex
seigneur de cette index deuxièmement
mais je n'aurais pas le temps d'aller
plus loin monsieur le rapporteur vous ai
raison sur un point c'est que la
question mérite d'être traitée dans une
globalité de la une nouvelle conception
du travail et si tu étais plus
alors je mets aux voix donc l'amendement
à Monsieur ferrique je ne vous avais pas
vu
quelques mots parce que c'est amendement
donc le 3465 est un amendement je dirais
d'une certaine façon structurante parce
que il c'est un amendement et qui il y
en a toute une série d'autres qui vont
dans le même sens et celui-là regroupe
une de nos principales préoccupations
qui est bien différente de ce
qu'affirmer rapporte tout à l'heure il
s'agit de d'établir un barème
d'évaluation des indicateurs d'établir
des sanctions pour résultat suffisants
différenciés selon la taille de
l'entreprise
le rapporteur nous dit que l'index à son
sens c'est une photo une photo d'une
situation un moment T ça ne doit pas
permettre je l'ai entendu tout à l'heure
de mesurer les évolutions que ça ne sert
pas à évoluer à évaluer pardon et encore
moins sanctionner cette photo si elle
est ce qu'il souhaite qu'elle soit ça me
semble une photo à la résolution bien
peut-être bien floue bien vague assez
inopérant
merci alors je mets donc aux voix donc
l'amendement 3465 a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient pas adopté
le monde
4656 même avis même vote même avis même
vote adopté le 1970 a été retiré je vais
mettre au voile les amendements
2015-2109 oui même
oui madame jasmin
Monsieur Laurent concernant justement
l'amendement 2015 de notre collègue
monsieur Hainaut alors dans la démarche
que j'ai entreprises de co-construction
et de co-production je souhaiterais
justement dans cette amendement notre
collègue il voudrait justement que l'on
relève
le nombre de salariés concernés de 50 à
300 et j'ai fait un amendement justement
concernant les territoires d'outre-mer
où il y a beaucoup de très petites
entreprises donc cet amendement qui
passe de 50 à 300 moi je propose dans un
autre amendement qui est beaucoup qui
est un peu plus loin que ce soit à 50
pour le territoire d'outre-mer parce que
nous avons des très petites entreprises
qui n'ont pas beaucoup de salariés et
300 c'est déjà exceptionnel voilà donc
je suis là pour co-construire nous
sommes dans la chambre haute merci
merci monsieur le président Laurent
ça marche pas malgré vos efforts merci
Monsieur Breuillet
merci vous attendez que je dise que on
n'a pas eu communication de la vie du
Conseil d'État mais je ne le dirai pas
chers collègues je ne le dirai pas
malgré vos demandes d'assistante bien
que je pense que c'est quand même
dommage que nous ne l'ayons pas eu mais
bon ça j'ai décidé de ne pas le dire non
je veux intervenir sur cet amendement
parce que au risque de choquer mes mes
amis et camarades de la gauche je dois
vous dire que je m'interrogeais beaucoup
pour ma part sur la question du seuil de
l'index et que cette question parce
qu'un seul il y a 50 c'est quand même
pas énormément d'effectifs salariés
quand on se dit qu'il doit y avoir un
équilibre des âges c'est une question
presque mathématique au fond quand les
âges sont établis et ben demander qui
est tel pourcentage de plus de 55 ans
c'est quand même assez difficile et pour
m'être occupé de petites structures je
me demandais comment je ferai avec un
seuil à 50 donc j'étais très favorable
pour ma part un seuil à 300 ou peut-être
plus intelligent à 250 enfin plus
intelligent non c'était pour faire un
compliment à Michel Calvet un seuil à
250 qui renvoyait à une autre situation
mais le problème qui nous est posé c'est
qu'on définit un seuil il y a aucun
critère il y a aucun critère et donc en
fait dans une petite entreprise on peut
mettre des critères sur le maintien en
âge par exemple on peut regarder s'il y
a des taux d'invalidité des taux de
licenciement qui sont spécifiques et
qu'il a peuvent concerner donc si on
avait des critères on pourrait dire bah
moi je soutiens l'amendement qui permet
de remonter à 300 et pour les 50 on
définit d'autres critères d'ailleurs je
rappelle que nous avons déposé des
amendements sens pour différencier les
critères donc malgré mes interrogations
que je livre publiquement dans cette
émission je ne voterai pas les
amendements Hainaut et Savary qui sont
identiques parce que nous n'avons aucune
lisibilité sur l'usage qui en sera fait
et du coup je préfère défendre qu'on
reste à une situation pour toutes les
entreprises monsieur Bruyer d'ailleurs
vous fait toujours manger des secondes
par nos collègues je vous le dis vous
devriez pas répondre au début
je vous le dis
je vais donner la parole à la commission
alors il y a madame et monsieur le
rapporteur pour une courte intervention
chacun oui je voulais déjà répondre je
ne sais plus à quel sénateur qui
demandait combien ça l'a reporté à la
CNAV oui ah pardon madame
linman et bien en tout cas ça rapporte
en tout cas tel que c'est indiqué dans
le tableau c'est 10 millions d'euros ce
qui est prévu la pénalité la pénalité
pour la en 2023 oui oui bien sûr puisque
justement ça commence seulement pour les
entreprises de plus de 1000 salariés
oui
alors je voulais aussi dire que à ce
stade de nos discussions que j'ai trouvé
fort intéressante puisqu'on parle des
seniors je voudrais dire que à 60 ans
finalement on peut considérer qu'on est
pas si vieux que ça puisque on est
plusieurs à avoir plus de 60 ans ici
certains plus de 62 + 64 et finalement
on tient bien la route on n'est pas
foutu on tient la route et et donc et
donc en fait on entend aussi bien ce qui
veulent arrêter avant que seuls qui
veulent continuer après non mais je vous
en prie j'ai pas dit ça non plus non
s'il vous plaît
dans chaque vieux il y a un jeune qui se
demande ce qui s'est passé c'est grosses
chemin c'est qui qui disait ça bon en
réalité
en réalité moi je crois beaucoup à
l'index seniors mais pas l'index le
Seigneur tout seul en réalité quand nous
avons travaillé à travers nos auditions
à travers les échanges qu'on a eu avec
René Paul et avec l'ensemble des
partenaires sociaux que nous avons
rencontrés avec l'ensemble des
entreprises des élus des associations
qui travaillent sur le travail des
seniors nous nous sommes dit il faut une
boîte à outils et l'index senior c'est
vrai que c'était plutôt porté par notre
groupe et puis René Paul nous a dit mais
pourquoi on mettrait pas en place un CDI
de fin de carrière et puis il y a aussi
des mesures qui seront proposées par la
suite sur l'incapacité permanente sur la
retraite progressive et tout ça ça
constitue un ensemble d'outils qui
seront intéressants mais je pense
qu'avant tous c'est la mentalité de la
société qu'il faut changer il faut
arrêter de penser que à partir d'un
certain âge on ne vaut plus rien ou
sinon que voilà d'aller je sais pas aux
champignons à la pêche et je ne sais où
mais en réalité on a des envies
différentes et c'est ça qu'il faut
accepter on a des centaines différentes
et on a des des intérêts différents on a
des passions différentes ce qu'il faut
ce qu'il faut avant tout se dire c'est
que cette différence cette diversité
c'est ça qui fait la richesse d'un pays
et que on ne doit pas abandonner
justement l'idée que à partir d'un
certain âge on ne peut pas être dans
l'entreprise et c'est donc la mentalité
des entreprises qu'il faut changer aussi
je pense qu'il faut que la société bouge
mais que l'entreprise bouge et c'est
peut-être avec ces petits outils qu'on
apporte aujourd'hui qu'on arrivera à
aider à plus embaucher des seniors à
plus les garder dans l'entreprise mais
pour le l'index le Seigneur je voudrais
revenir sur cette idée d'index madame la
rapporteur parce que vous êtes deux à
avoir demandé la parole alors je vais un
peu partager
de la Merci beaucoup excusez-moi
non simplement en dessous de 50 nous
avons pensé qu'effectivement il y avait
pas l'air ressources humaines dans les
entreprises votre intervention madame
nous a interpellé également
pour les outre-mer on voit bien que
c'est pas un dispositif performant c'est
pour ça qu'il faut vraiment la
il faut vraiment le travailler et que
les spécificités régionales soient
prises en compte dans un cadre national
bon on n'a pas souhaité la dire on va
faire des seuils différents pour les
outre-mer mais ça nous interpelle bien
évidemment deuxièmement le taux d'emploi
des 55 64 ans c'est
vous madame Liman j'ai homis de vous
répondre mais je pense que il faut être
précis vous ne vous avez dit je crois
bien que la réforme ou c'est Monsieur
Laurent peut-être bien que la réforme de
2010 ça veut dire c'est vous merci la
réforme la réforme de 2010 n'avait
aucunement sur le taux d'emploi des
seniors c'était très long mais ça c'est
fait j'ai 2010 taux d'emploi des seniors
les 55 64 ceux qui nous préoccupe ce
sont ceux-là parce que quand on fait la
statistique à 60 on peut avoir des c'est
cette progression la 55 64 je pense que
là qu'il faut considérer seniors avant
quand même c'était peut-être il y a 20
ans ça commence à 45 ans maintenant ça
commence et à 55 ans quand vous êtes
seniors quand vous reprenez vous êtes au
chômage si vous arrivez la chance 13%
seulement actuellement qui retrouve de
l'emploi c'est un emploi stable et vous
pouvez s'il y a des engagements d'où le
CDI seniors former ce seigneur justement
mais une formation adaptée au Seigneur
qui est pas à la même que vous faites
aux jeunes c'est comme ça qu'on réglera
les problèmes 40,5% d'emploi des 55 64
ans 2013 47
enfin on arrive à 53,8 vous voyez c'est
la conséquence et forcément progressive
ça peut pas être du jour au lendemain
c'est pour ça que dans les études
d'impact quand on fait le rendement des
mesures à l'horizon 2030 on s'est fixé
c'est le gouvernement qui a fixé là on
fait un rendement de mesure je vais vous
dire vous faites le rendement en 2027
parce que 2027 ça correspond à la
trajectoire de des finances publiques
c'est pas le même rendement et si vous
attendez derrière vous faites une autre
photographie en 2032 c'est un autre
rendement donc soyons attentif à tous
merci merci beaucoup alors j'ai été
saisie d'une demande de scrutin public
par le groupe CRCE sur les amendements
2015 et 2109 je vous rappelle que la vie
de la commission est favorable et la vie
du gouvernement et sagesse va être
procédé au Scott un public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
alors résultat du scrutin nombre de
votants 343 exprimer 342 pour 247 contre
95 le Sénat a adopté ses amendements et
je passe à l'amendement
2750 4 fois c'est deux amendements
identiques plutôt
2754 et le 41059 qui est pour
qui est contre qui se tient ne sont pas
adoptés
pour
contre qui s'abstient
adopté
l'amendement 4655 pour
pardon 4654 excusez-moi j'ai mes
lunettes ça va pas bien donc pour contre
qui s'abstient une base adoptée
l'amendement 4136
qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient pas adopté l'amendement 3466
qui est pour contre qui s'abstient très
adopté un moment 4145 et pour contre qui
s'abstient n'est pas adopté même ma vie
même vote pour le 4150 et 1
pareil pour le 4142 merci donc ils ne
sont pas adoptés
même avis même vote merci
3177 même vote 4163
le 2759
le 3731 4171
identiques
pareil le 2758
le 2 4176 le 2756 le 2479
les 2480 2757 et 4179
le 46
le 3423
je suis désolé d'interrompre cette belle
course mais juste mais j'ai écouté et si
j'ai bien compris ce que dit Monsieur le
Ministre mon amendement est satisfait
donc je le retire
tout ça pour ça donc il reste le 2947
le 2945
47 donc avis défavorable de la
commission du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient merci le
3194 même avis même vote le 3732
le
2480 le 2755 le 325
le 3109
le 4183 le
3123152
mais bon
3178 et 4186
le 279 pardon c'est ça suit pas
non mais là
c'est bon c'est bon je peux continuer
oui je crois que
je ne suis pas le 2784
4189 voilà on a un scrutin public sur le
demandée par le groupe CRCE donc la vie
défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement il va être procédé au
scrutin public
oui c'est ça va passer vite les machines
en fait vous voyez
il va être procédé au scrutin public
donc dans les conditions fixées par
l'article 56 du règlement
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
alors résultat du scrutin nombre de
votants 343 exprimé 343 pour 91 contre
252 le Sénat n'a pas adopté ses âmes cet
amendement alors l'amendement
2483 avis défavorable deux avis
défavorables qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient qui est adopté le 3734
même avis même vote le 3735 pardon
je sais
alors je sais qu'il est pas à jour mais
parce que il va pas aussi vite que nous
il est en train de sénateur c'est ça la
machine
alors est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est
bon
ah vous voulez le nom de d'accord
d'accord parce que moi je vous j'entends
pas en fait d'accord donc là je suis au
3735 de Monsieur Fernique voilà
donc avis défavorable qui est pour qui
est contre qui s'abstient n'est pas
adopté de 3736 de Monsieur Ferny mais ma
vie même vote ok le 3737 de Monsieur
Ferny mais ma vie même vote
et là j'ai un scrutin public sur le 2484
de Monsieur dossu le 2785 de Madame
Lubin le 4198 de même assassin
donc on va mettre il va être procédé
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement je
vous rappelle que la vie est les deux
avis sont défavorables le scrutin est
ouvert
mandat voter le scrutin clos
résultat du scrutin nombre de votants
343 exprimé 342 pour 91 contre 2051 le
Sénat n'a pas adopté
donc le 3738 de Monsieur Ferny
favorables qui est pour Monsieur
Fernique voilà qui est contre qui
s'abstient n'est pas adopter le
2485 de Monsieur do su et le 4200 1 de
Madame assassy même avis même vote merci
ensuite j'ai le 197 de Monsieur Savin le
233 de Monsieur Kern le 1012 de Monsieur
Lauzac avis défavorable deux avis
défavorables
mais ma vie même vote à peu près non
mais
alors qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient sont pas adoptés
maintenant le
2787 de Madame Lubin et le 425 de madame
assassy
qui est deux avis défavorables qui est
pour contre qui s'abstients ne sont pas
adoptés sur le
3742 monsieur ferick et le 4213 de
Madame assassin nous avons inscrit un
public avec deux avis défavorables il va
donc être procédé au scrutin public dans
les conditions fixées par l'article 56
du règlement le scrutin est ouvert
ça ne demande à voter le scrutin est
clos
un résultat du scrutin nombre de votants
343 exprimés 342 pour 91 contre 251 le
Sénat n'a pas adopté ses amendements
nous passons à l'amendement
3739 de Monsieur Fernier de David
défavorables même avis tout à l'heure
la même vote
les deux amendements suivants 4217 de
même assassis et le 4157 de Madame Vogel
même avis même vote merci
alors ensuite j'ai la deux amendements
identiques 2014
3390 avec
une demande de retrait de la commission
Navy favorable du Gouvernement monsieur
Hainaut vous ne retirez pas non
monsieur lévrier fast et Monsieur
patrian non plus donc je mets aux voix
donc ces deux amendements je rappelle à
vie favorable du Gouvernement
avis défavorable de la commission qui
est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
sont pas adoptés
je passe donc à l'amendement 2793 de
Madame Lubin de David et favorable la
même avis même votre que tout à l'heure
vous voulez le refaire on va le refaire
non non vous êtes ce n'est pas non non
c'était avant ces deux-là voilà mais si
vous voulez je refais non c'est bon
voilà
4224 de madame
assassy est en scrutin public
avec deux avis des favorables il va donc
être procédé au scrutin public
incondition fixée par l'article 56 du
règlement le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
les résultats du scrutin nombre de
votants 343 exprimés 342 pour 91 contre
251 le Sénat n'a pas adopté et je passe
à l'amendement 179 de Monsieur Milon qui
a reçu donc à David et favorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour
non non pas celui-ci vous l'avez pas
retiré monsieur Milan celui-ci voilà
donc qui est pour personne qui est
contre
qui s'abstient donc la personne bon
amendement 2792 de Madame Lubin je vais
reprendre qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstiente pas adopter le 4228 de
Madame assassy même avis même vote
le 2486 de Monsieur do sur ma ma vie
même vote
ensuite j'ai le 3741 de Monsieur ferick
le 42009 de Madame assassy mamadie même
vote
2791 de Madame Lubin
idem le 2788 de Madame Lubin pareil le
2790 de Madame Lubin pareil le 2789 de
Madame Lubin pareil le 3745 de Monsieur
Fernique le 3744 de Monsieur Ferny le
3743 de Monsieur Ferny le 3742 de
Monsieur Ferny le
2948 de Madame Monnier le 2794 de Madame
Lubin
le
4243 de Madame assassy les amendements
identiques de 1795 4229 donc même Lubin
et Madame assassy nous avons une demande
de scrutin public
avec un avis donc à double avis
défavorable et va être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement
le scrutin est ouvert
2795 et 4229 qui sont identiques
donc même Lubin voilà même Lubin pour le
premier madame assis pour le deuxième
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
résultat du scrutin nombre de votants
343 exprimé 342 pour 91 contre 251 le
Sénat n'a pas adopté ses amendements
mais on voit maintenant le 2322 de
monsieur babary qui a reçu il est retiré
merci
donc le 4155 de Madame assassy donc même
avis même vote que tout à l'heure
2797 de Madame Lubin même a vu même vote
voilà vis-à-monde en 1796 et 4244 donc
Madame Lubin Massassi mais ma vie même
vote
le 3126 de même penser Monge
le alors la maman 2297 de Madame Boulay
esperonier donc qui a reçu un avis
défavorable à la Commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstiente pas
adopté les amendements 2798 et 3746 même
Lubin et Monsieur fernick même avis un
vote le 2799 de Madame Lubin
identique de 1802 madame Lubin
le 3175 de même pensé mon jeu
le
3469 de même poncer Monge le 2800 de
Madame Lubin pareil le 2801 de Madame
Lubin
alors avant sur l'amendement donc là on
va procéder donc au vote de l'amendement
de 1803 et 4248 213 de Madame Lubin le
deuxième dememas assis et Madame gréaume
m'avait demandé la parole j'avais noté
madame
merci
cet amendement de repli visa instauré
une obligation trillionale de
négociation au sein des branches
professionnelles portant sur l'emploi
des seniors il manque encore des
décisions fortes pour permettre à tous
de travailler jusqu'à la retraite or la
réforme des retraites souhaitées par le
gouvernement ne pourraient se faire sans
que soit porté une véritable politique
publique en faveur de l'emploi des
seniors permettant leur maintien et leur
retour à l'emploi concluez le président
d'une association d'aide au retour à
l'emploi nous entendons ici à défaut de
mieux que les branches professionnelles
et une négociation sur les conditions de
travail des seniors d'aménagement de
leur temps et sur les fins de carrière
il apparaît nécessaire également
d'encourager les entreprises à porter
une plus grande attention aux pénibilité
il convient donc d'organiser des
négociations régulières et s'agitient
merci merci alors je vais donc
passer au scrutin public donc pour ces
deux amendements monsieur brouillés
pas de souci
bien qu'il y a aucun souci et je vous
remercie beaucoup madame la Présidente
non je voulais juste redire un mot parce
que tout à l'heure dans la discussion de
l'ensemble des amendements il a été
souligné une volonté que j'ai cru
comprendre partager sur tous les bancs
d'associer les organisations syndicales
alors c'est amendement
est ainsi rédigé qu'il demande qu'une
négociation soit conduite avec les
organisations syndicales de salariés et
d'employeurs représentatives au niveau
national et interprofessionnel en vue de
la définition des indicateurs et des
objectifs chiffrés d'amélioration des
conditions d'emplois et d'embauche des
salariés
âgé de 50 ans et plus dans le cadre des
différents décrets mentionnés à cet
article donc franchement excusez-moi je
me permets de faire cette incise on est
en train de passer rapidement les
amendements les uns et les autres dans
une dans la
l'allégresse générale mais sur cet
amendement là je dis évidemment que je
le voterai mais j'invite chacun le voté
puisqu'il est conforme aux engagements
que j'ai entendu
du rapporteur du ministre et sans doute
aussi sur les bancs de l'ensemble des
collègues
merci madame la Présidente dans le droit
fil de ceux qui viennent d'être dit il y
a également des syndicats des
organisations syndicales au niveau local
et monsieur le rapporteur Savary il faut
poser justement lors des négociations
lors du travail qui va faire avec le
gouvernement qu'il y ait des
possibilités au niveau local parce qu'il
y avait des petites entreprises donc je
souhaite que monsieur le rapporteur
Samarie retienne qu'il faudrait
également proposer que les syndicats des
partenaires sociaux qui sont locaux
parce qu'il y a dans tous les
territoires d'outre-mer des syndicats
qui sont peut-être pour certains
représentés au niveau national mais au
niveau local il y en a aussi donc il
faudrait les inclure dans la démarche je
vous remercie merci donc je vais passer
au scrutin public donc sur ces deux
amendements de 1803 et 4248 le scrutin
public a été demandé par le groupe CRCE
deux avis défavorables
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement
le scrutin est ouvert
ne demanda voter le scrutin est clos
résultat du scrutin nombre de votants
343 exprimés 342 pour 91 contre 251 le
Sénat n'a pas adopté
et donc nous passons à l'amendement 2804
de Madame Lubin même avis même vote
le 2805 de même Lubin même avis même
vote
le 3470 de même penser
le 3471 même pensé mange
alors le 2110 de Monsieur Savary qui a
reçu un avis de sagesse du gouvernement
donc qui est pour
lever un peu les mains ça vous fera un
peu d'exercice
tu es contre
qui s'abstient et donc adopter
et donc il fait tomber le 2018 le 3472
le 4249 le 2359 et le 2946
et donc là je vais mettre au voile à mon
en 211 de Monsieur Savary avis de
sagesse du gouvernement qui est pour qui
est contre qui s'abstient il est donc
adopté
on fait une 2616 de Madame Lubin qui a
reçu un avis défavorable du gouvernement
de la commission qui est pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient mais donc pas
adopter donc nous passons à cinq
amendements faisons l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 3180 madame ponce
même pensé
ah non non pas du tout là on passe vous
avez
ils sont défendus madame poncemonge il y
en a cinq 3180 3482
3477 et
3475 qui sont des demandes de rapport
donc
alors 3180 non mais je suis persuadé que
vous voulez quand même savoir si vous
allez le voter
donc le présent article souhaite mettre
en place un index qui concerne les
entreprises de plus de 50 salariés
toutefois aucune disposition n'est
prévue concernant le contrôle de
l'application du dit index le présent
amendement propose donc d'envisager un
renforcement des contrôles de la mise en
place de l'index et des efforts réalisés
par les entreprises pour améliorer
substantiellement l'emploi et la qualité
des emplois des seniors qui est notre
but à tout le groupe écologique
solidarité était et territoires rappelle
également que mettre en place des
contrôles de l'index et plus largement
le contrôle des pratiques et des
comportements des entreprises en matière
conditions de travail et d'égale
traitement implique nécessairement de
renforcer les moyens de l'inspection du
travail selon le dernier rapport de la
Cour des comptes de 2020 l'organisme
manque d'effectif dédié au contrôle ce
qui entrave sa mission la France devrait
compter 2000 inspecteurs soient un
inspecteur pour 10000 salariés il en
manque actuellement plus de 300 avec une
baisse de 9% au total entre 2014 et 2018
donc afin d'éviter une telle situation
nous appelons donc à la mise en place de
contrôle solide de l'application de
l'index senior pour que cet outil ne
soit pas ce qui malheureusement je crois
est le cas une simple formalité sans
réel impact je vous remercie
si
le 3482 est défendu
vaillamment alors le présent amendement
propose d'envisager le renforcement des
sanctions financières en cas de résultat
insuffisants l'index actuel ne propose
en effet de sanctions financières qu'en
cas de non publication de la Dex ce qui
ne force nullement les entreprises à
avoir des résultats satisfaisants en
matière d'emploi des seniors s'il y a de
sérieux doutes quand un impact de cette
index senior contenu du flou sur la
définition enfin à ce stade des
indicateurs et de l'obligation serait
l'obligation se restreignant à ce jour à
la simple publication il est donc à
minima nécessaire de mettre en place des
sanctions en cas de résultat négatifs
sans quoi l'index aura une portée nulle
pour notre sujet
le 3474
et oui encore le modèle de l'index sur
l'égalité professionnelle femme homme
nous allons démontrer je dirais sont
relative
inefficacité à corriger effectivement
les inégalités de gens c'est beaucoup
dur aux indicateurs je crois que ça a
été bien démontré à plusieurs reprises
du fait de l'impression des indicateurs
lors de la conception du dispositif qui
a manqué de faire un vrai
diagnostic des causes justement de
l'écart des salaires entre les hommes et
des femmes j'en ai parlé temps partiel
imposée discrimination des secteurs de
façon genre quand au niveau des
qualifications la discrimination pure
est quand même le la part la plus
réduite les entreprises peut aujourd'hui
passer entre les mailles de ce filet et
obtenir une note favorable
donc
merci donc le
convaincre de voter l'un de des 5
amendements suivants que je présente
et c'est alinéa donc envisage de
soumettre l'adoption du décret
mentionné au deuxième alinéa de
l'article
l51-7 du Code du travail à la
concertation entre le gouvernement et
les organisations syndicales de salariés
et d'employeurs représentatives au
niveau national et
interprofessionnels et à plusieurs
reprises vous avez souligné votre
attachement à la négociation sociale et
au dialogue social donc voici enfin un
amendement soumis par les écologistes
que vous allez pouvoir voter mais cette
concertation sous-entend des faits un
affaiblissement autrement du rôle des
partenaires sociaux dans la définition
des politiques concernant directement
les salariés voilà et enfin
et enfin
l'amendement donc
3475 le présent dispositif propose
d'adapter par convention ou accorde
branche la liste initiale des
indicateurs et de leur méthode de calcul
établies par décret
si cela peut permettre une meilleure
prise en compte des spécificités de
chaque milieu professionnel que ça soit
la branche ou l'entreprise il y a
néanmoins un risque quand un accord
défavorable aux intérêts des salariés
ces indicateurs soient revus à la baisse
et moi je suis attaché au principe de
faveur de la hiérarchie des normes c'est
pour ça je défends le groupe écologiste
aussi solidarité territoire avec moi
propose donc une évaluation de cette
modalité d'adaptation de l'index par
accord de branche pour voir si les
accords de branches sont plus favorables
effectivement que le cadre législatif si
s'il vous plaît non mais s'il vous plaît
un tout petit peu de calme et de et de
respect voilà c'est bon alors la vie de
la commission même la rapporteur
oui merci madame la Présidente
l'ensemble de ces amendements demande en
réalité qu'il soit fait un certain
nombre d'évaluations et de contrôle sur
l'application de cet article 2 et donc
c'est un avis défavorable de la
commission parce que nous considérons
que effectivement le ministère du
Travail et les travaux de la DARES
pourront permettre d'avoir ces ensembles
d'évaluation que que vous souhaiteriez à
travers des rapports et je pense aussi
que le travail d'évaluation et de
contrôle du Sénat peut nous permettre
d'obtenir ces éléments c'est donc un
avis défavorable merci la vie du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
défavorable merci alors je vais mettre
au voie donc l'amendement 3180 qui a
reçu donc un avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient n'est pas
adopter le 3482 même avis même vote
le
3474 même avis même vote merci le 3477
merci
sur le
3475 je saisis d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe geste avec donc un
avis défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement il va être procédé
scrutable public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement le
scrutin est ouvert
ça ne demande à voter le scrutin clos
alors nombre de votants 343 exprimés 342
pour 147 contre 195 le Sénat n'a pas
adopté
nous allons passer au vote de l'article
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je vais me
prononcer contre l'adoption de cet
article 2 et je souhaiterais évoquer en
conclusion du débat autour de cet
article et la problématique des femmes
seniors confronté à une double peine sur
le marché de l'emploi les données de la
DARES en date de 2021 indique que parmi
les 55 64 ans les taux d'emploi et
d'activités sont plus bas pour les
femmes
54,3% et 57,9 que pour les hommes
57,7 et
61,7%. en France le taux d'emploi des
femmes seniors est égal à la moyenne
européenne alors qu'il inférieur de de
près de 10 points pour les hommes à la
persistance des représentants associés à
l'ensemble des seniors sur la difficulté
à s'adapter aux évolutions
technologiques à être moins habiles leur
coût réputés trop important alors qu'il
est en réalité le reflet de leur
expérience s'ajoute en effet autres
obstacles propres aux femmes un lestar
des interruptions de carrière ou recours
au temps partiel pour relever leurs
enfants et pour les proches en qualité
des dentes les femmes âgées sont ainsi
confrontés à encore plus de difficultés
pour retrouver du travail après un
licenciement ou se réinsérer sur le
marché de l'emploi c'est aussi pour elle
que nous devons avoir le courage d'aller
plus loin et d'inciter le gouvernement à
proposer une réponse davantage à la
hauteur de l'enjeu que cette index
senior
rouge
merci madame la Présidente
d'abord
tout à l'heure Xavier yakovelli a
souligner l'incohérence de notre
démarche collective sur les bancs de la
gauche c'est assez savoureux de sa part
quand on connaît sa cohérence politique
personnelle
sur le fond
qu'est-ce que change cette index à la
Brulat à la brutalité de la réforme rien
rien du tout on a une mesure qui fait
ici simplement écran de fumée on a une
mesure qui est déclarative et dont le
rapporteur c'est très bien qu'elle
n'aura pas d'effet de la même façon
madame la rapporteur vous disiez que la
retraite peut être un temps heureux mais
pas pour tout le monde vous oubliez je
vous le rappelle que à 62 ans il y a un
quart des plus pauvres qui sont déjà
décédés et que si on projette cette
tendance à 64 ans on dépassera
probablement les 33% d'après les
projections
et donc la différence de vie entre les
catégories socio-professionnelles elle
est réelle et cette réforme va venir
fracasser toute une partie de la
population et manifestement ça vous va
très bien et ça ne vous pose aucune
difficulté c'est sans doute là notre
différence principale ce qui va se
passer c'est que les seniors notamment
les plus précaires vont justement être
poussés dans une trappe à pauvreté je
vous rappelle que l'étude qui a été
publiée le 1er mars dans Libération
montre très bien le lien entre l'âge de
départ et le chômage des seniors et
cette relation est complètement
confirmée pour toute pour toutes ces
raisons pour toutes ces brutalités pour
cette injustice que vous générez bien
entendu un index déclaratif ne peut être
suffisant
la seule mesure qui serait suffisante
c'est
le retrait de cette
réforme à laquelle vous vous crispez
depuis maintenant des années merci
Madame Cohen
merci madame la Présidente en France
entre 50 et 55 ans quand ce n'est pas
des 45 ans sur le marché du travail vous
êtes souvent considéré comme vieux et
c'est pire encore si vous êtes une femme
comme ma collègue vient le souligner
pour les seniors il est toujours plus
difficile de poursuivre une fin de
carrière dans son entreprise ou de
retrouver du travail lorsqu'on est privé
d'emploi c'est une réalité cette
question n'est pas abordée et pourtant
nous le savons la culture des âges qui
reste dominante dans nos entreprises
favorise la marginalisation la
relégation de nombreux salariés diag
cela avait 20 ans que les gouvernements
successifs s'attaquent aux droits à la
retraite tout en incitant les
entreprises à agir en faveur de l'emploi
des salariés âgés accords et plan senior
en 2008 contrat de généralisation de
génération pardon de 2013 CDD seniors
CDI inclusion chaque gouvernement a fait
le pari que le recul de l'âge de la
retraite augmenterait mécaniquement le
taux d'emploi des seniors ce qui ce qui
concerne plutôt les salariés déjà en
poste en CDI mais ce qui était le plus
éloigné de l'emploi n'ont jamais été
miraculeusement embauché suite aux
réformes successives et il n'y aura pas
plus de miracles avec votre réforme
monsieur le ministre pire Pôle Emploi
enregistré que les 50 ans et plus
représentaient les deux tiers du volume
des ruptures de contrat en 2020 on a
donc assisté avec la pandémie un grand
retour des mesures d'âge et d'une
gestion de l'emploi par la sortie
anticipée des travailleurs en fin de
carrière sortie anticipé que
l'euphémisme pour parler de chômage de
précarité et de paupérisation en
attendant la retraite c'est pourquoi si
vous vouliez réellement inciter
l'embauche et le maintien des salariés
seniors en entreprise il aurait fallu
par exemple
majorer la cotisation d'assurance
vieillesse à la charge de l'employeur en
l'absence d'un accord collectif
d'entreprise ou d'un plan d'action en
faveur de l'emploi des seniors
applicables à l'entreprise ce n'est pas
le sens de l'article vous n'avez accepté
aucun de nos amendements pour enrichir
ce texte nous voterons contre merci
Madame linman
il est clair que la réforme va
détériorer les conditions de vie d'un
très grand nombre de seniors
ça va créer une grande anxiété c'est
toute une série de nos concitoyens qui
déjà dans le système actuel pouvait
espérer rapidement passer en retraite et
qui vont rester durablement dans une
trappe soit pauvreté soit précarité et
en tout cas dans des très mauvaises
conditions et c'est non seulement les
plus modestes mais c'est ces fameux
ouvriers dont on aurait tant besoin pour
réindustrialiser le pays or justement si
on veut que ces métiers soient valorisés
c'est pas en leur prévoyant une fin de
vie difficile que nous allons le faire
la question des seniors est toute façon
importante indépendamment de votre
retraite qui va nous faire qu'à croître
la situation
et on ne peut pas la distinguer d'une
évaluation du rapport des Français au
travail
nous sommes le pays de l'Union
européenne et ça c'est pas vos
statistiques de cotisations sociales de
dépenses publiques qui avons le plus de
salariés qui sont considérés qui sont
considèrent ne pas être reconnu pris en
compte écoutez valoriser dans leur
entreprise
c'est quand même une crise majeure alors
après vous pouvez toujours dire les
Français ont plus d'appétence au travail
forcément
si l'organisation de la vie du travail
le management des entreprises la manière
dont les organisations syndicales c'est
de la variées sont prises en compte dans
les entreprises est mauvaise évidemment
la pétance de travail est limitée et
évidemment quand vous arrivez dans ces
mécanismes peu attentifs à l'humain à la
démarche de chacun aux démarches
collectives mais quand les gens arrivent
à la fin leur carrière professionnelle
ils sont trop souvent jetés comme un
kleenex mais si même Lubin
oui nous aussi nous nous voterons contre
contre cet article mais avec beaucoup de
regrets quand même je dois le dire
nous considérons depuis le début que
cette index est un gadget je vais pas le
redire mais nous avons très franchement
déposé des amendements qui pouvaient
apporter le débat des amendements
sérieux et
qui pour certains je l'ai déjà dit
émaner d'un travail que nous avons fait
en commun avec le rapporteur donc
j'avoue que je ne comprends pas très
bien qu'au moins quelques-uns n'ont
trouvé aucune grâce de la commission
mais c'est pas grave au-delà de ce vote
de ce soir il faut rappeler quand même
que
l'incongruité consiste à nous annoncer
une loi travail
après avoir voté
éventuellement ce PLFSS
rectificatif bon c'est assez curieux
puis surtout je pense que au-delà de
tout ce que on peut proposer voter
jusqu'à maintenant c'était aussi une
déconclusions du travail que nous avons
fait que nous avions fait avec René Paul
Savary rien n'a fonctionné
ni la coercition ni l'encouragement ni
les primes les réductions d'impôts rien
du tout il y a une espèce de culture
française au delà de aller 55 ans on est
vraiment plus bon arrière comme l'a dit
Laurence Cohen et il y a eu des
témoignages dernièrement dans la presse
très intéressante quand on est une femme
de plus de 50 ans sur le marché du
travail c'est absolument
catastrophique et donc au-delà de tout
ce que nous pourrons inventer moi je
pense que c'est surtout une négociation
avec les entreprises j'ai envie de dire
quasi quotidienne et un changement de
paradigme qu'il va falloir inventer
merci à Monsieur Savoldelli
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues
nous voterons compte pour plusieurs
raisons parce que cette question de
l'index peut pas être sortie du contexte
de la loi
et là je vous le redis je pense que
malheureusement on va le vérifier
reculer l'âge de la retraite de deux ans
va mettre davantage de seniors en
difficulté et en précarité
la deuxième chose que je veux dire c'est
à notre collègue Jean-Paul Savary c'est
il a évoqué la période de la réforme de
2010 avec les effets en 2011 je conteste
pas les chiffres qu'il a donné ils sont
vrais mais une petite ambition quand
même c'est qu'elle en 2011 il y a eu des
mesures spécifiques il y a eu la
suppression des dispositifs de cessation
anticipées d'activité et des dispenses
de recherche d'emploi ce qui explique le
relèvement du taux d'activité vous voyez
donc autant dire tout pour se parler
pourquoi dire ça parce que nous avons
fait des propositions et il y en avait
une et c'est là que là je dis au
gouvernement je sais pas je sais pas si
on peut appeler ça humilité monsieur le
ministre mais qu'est-ce que vous dites
aux travailleurs aux travailleuses qui
depuis 2017 vous avez supprimé tous les
critères de pénibilité vous leur dites
quoi ça va être rétroactif l'index non 6
ans 6 années de perdu
et nous nous étions pour qu'il y ait
nous des départs anticipés avant 60 ans
et pourquoi pas manière mécanique c'est
qu'on revisite ici le Parlement tous les
critères de pénibilité beaucoup ont été
évoqué ici sur des métiers extrêmement
pidicules physiquement etc mais c'est
vrai pour les cadres avec des maladies
nouvelles avec le stress le burn-out
l'intensité au travail etc on était en
capacité ici de réfléchir à des critères
de pénibilité nouveau on s'en est
interdit avec cette index dernière chose
c'est la constitutionnalité de l'objet
franchement monsieur le ministre et et
mesdames messieurs de la qui dirigeait
notre commission qu'est-ce que vient
faire un index senior dans une loi de
finances
il fallait que ça soit c'est index
senior devait être dans une un projet de
loi soit dédié soit dans la loi travail
merci madame la Présidente comme vous
l'avez compris nous avons en toute
conscience voulue enrichir ce texte
cette proposition qui est mal placée en
fait on a entendu les précédents
orateurs mais nous avons quand même au
niveau du groupe socialiste mais aussi
sur les bancs de la gorge voulu pour le
principe de précaution prendre les
mesures et faire un certain nombre de
suggestions nous avons proposé des
amendements j'ai moi-même interpellé et
faire reconnaître qu'il y avait moins de
médecins du travail qui avait moins
d'inspecteur pour vérifier les
conditions de travail et l'ergonomie au
sein des entreprises j'ai également
interpellé sur les questions de
prévention et des risques psychosociaux
l'amélioration continue de la qualité au
sein de l'entreprise vous avez fait
comme si nous n'avions rien apporté
pourtant ce n'était pas incohérent de
notre part de pouvoir enrichir cette
proposition bien au contraire nous
étions contre et pense que nous aimons
les travailleurs parce que nous voulons
impliquer les partenaires sociaux parce
la population nous regarde également
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de personnes en
souffrance dans les entreprises et nous
avons voulu tenter de trouver les
meilleures solutions possibles pour ces
personnes là et pour toutes ces raisons
là je voudrais contre l'ensemble de
notre groupe votre compte mais il a déjà
dit mais je voudrais quand même que vous
puissiez le dire parce que nous avons
proposé des amendements en groupe ou
individuellement pour tenter d'améliorer
d'améliorer ce que vous souhaitez faire
mais là c'est vraiment dramatique ce que
vous êtes en train de proposer à ceux
qui nous regardent et à tous les
travailleurs particulièrement les femmes
donc depuis le mois de juillet de
janvier pardon j'ai interpellé monsieur
le ministre lors des questions
gouvernement et j'ai parlé de la
problématique des femmes les femmes qui
payent un look Libye et qui vont encore
payer un autre tribu alors quand j'avoue
que certaines de vos assistants monsieur
le ministre passe leur temps à rigoler
je trouve que c'est insultant pour le
Parlement merci merci
oui merci même les présidentes alors je
voudrais revenir sur paraît-il le
paradoxe qu'il y a qui a eu à faire
effectivement pour beaucoup d'entre nous
déposés un amendement de suppression de
cette index et puis ensuite et bien à le
discuter il n'y a aucun paradoxe je
tiens à le redire si nous avons demandé
sa suppression c'est parce
qu'effectivement c'est un cavalier
social qui a de forts risques pour que
de toute façon ça sorte de la loi et
donc sa place ici à une place d'alibi et
on voit bien de toute façon que c'est
bien prématuré que DE TOUTE c'est que
c'est que les amendements que nous avons
porté beaucoup d'amendements sont issus
des organisations syndicales donc ça
montre bien que les organisations
syndicales sont en train d'en discuter
dans un cadre plus large je l'ai dit
Daniel
plus plus large donc nous nous en avons
porté avec eux quelquefois de notre
propre initiative en tant que parti
politique
et là c'était normal puisque vous nous
avez en quelque sorte vous avez maintenu
cet index qui sera sorti et puisque vous
l'avez maintenu et bien on a commencé la
discussion cette discussion n'est pas
inutile puisque nous allons la retrouver
dans une loi où elle aura sa place donc
nous avons travaillé de façon sérieuse
et nous avons pris nous avons avancé là
par rapport à une loi mais vraiment dire
que les syndicats voulaient qu'on
discute de la Dex 2 c'est possible à
partir du moment où elle est maintenue
mais quand je vois le sort que vous avez
fait à tous les amendements qui sont
issus désorganisations syndicales et de
toutes les organisations syndicales de
salariés je doute vraiment que c'est de
votre sincérité à ce propos
merci alors je vais donc mettre au bois
j'ai été saisie d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe des socialistes et
le groupe des communistes sur l'article
tout de suite vous voulez prendre la
parole ou après
[Musique]
au point où on en est on est plus une
minute près simplement pour répondre à
Raymonde pour Simon la Commission n'a
pas
par mon intermédiaire n'a pas refusé
comme ça d'un revers de mal ses
amendements puisque les propositions que
vous faites on les partage la différence
simplement c'est que nous disons c'est
au partenaires sociaux de fixer les
indicateurs accords de branches la
branche voilà va fixer va voir comment
ils peuvent être évolutifs très
important l'évolution derrière des
indicateurs nous on a pensé faire comme
la gestion prévisionnelle tous les
quatre ans peut-être qu'il y a des
branches un peu plus d'autres c'est un
peu moins et puis ensuite les
consultations c'est les partenaires
sociaux donc vos amendements sont tout à
fait pertinents simplement nous les
placerons dans une loi travail plutôt
que dans une loi retraite
voilà il était important qu'on conclut
bons amis en ce qui concerne les maires
de famille nous
partageons vos préoccupations c'est la
raison pour laquelle vous verrez qu'on
propose quelque chose de une surcote
pour les maires de famille qui sont
arrivés à taux plein avant l'âge légal
de départ pour leur permettre si elles
ont des majorations trimestres d'avoir
une surcote c'est quand même un élément
important qui réduit les différences de
pension entre les hommes et les femmes
et puis la pénibilité article 9 là aussi
vous verrez que il est incontestable
qu'il faut prendre en compte mieux la
pénibilité les 10 critères sont là
puisqu'on réintroduit le critère des
agents chimiques on sépare effectivement
il s'est complexe la prise en compte de
la pénibilité à travers les quatre
critères l'ec2p par rapport à ceux qui
sont dans les trous ergonomiques qui
sont traités différemment on fait plus
de mesures de prévention par rapport à
la réparation donc on pourra se
retrouver me semble-t-il sur soi-même si
on va encore jusqu'à l'article 9 merci
merci alors donc je vais mettre au bois
donc avec le scrutin public
il va être procédé donc au scrutin
public dans les conditions fixée par
l'article 56 du règlement et le scrutin
est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
résultat du scrutin nombre de votants
343 exprimer 340 pour 244 contre 96 le
Sénat a adopté l'article de
[Musique]
alors
mes chers collègues je vais lever la
séance nous savons examiné 258
amendements cours de la journée il en
reste 311 à examiner sur ce texte
prochaine séance Lundi 6 mars à 10h pour
la suite de l'examen du projet de loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023 la séance est levée